so Elon Musk just put up a Twitter poll
reinstate former president Trump of
course I clicked yes and right now
there's over a half a million 550 000
votes about 63 percent say yes that's
cool Elon Musk also reinstated The
Babylon B Jordan Peterson and Kathy
Griffin but he is outright refused to
reinstate Alex Jones even going so far
as to respond to Viva fry saying too bad
and that's actually fairly brutal
because I can understand you know Alex
Jones has issued a response already
saying don't blame Elon you know he's
the most controversial guy in the world
no no I get that and I would agree but I
don't understand why Elon is taking it
upon himself to kind of rub in that he
doesn't actually believe in free speech
and he's kind of just you know spitting
on us in that regard but look I'll take
a win I'll take a win right unbanning
these people if he brings back Trump
these are all really really good things
but uh let's not pretend like the guy
actually cares about Free Speech now to
be fair I get it
he probably can't reinstate Alex Jones
without it's like it would be like
dropping a bomb on the platform but
again I'll stress it he could have just
ignored the question or he could have
said something like we have to have a
review process he could have been honest
and said something like you know Alex
Jones is very controversial
controversial so we're going to have to
have a deep look at that and it may not
be possible or something like that but
instead it's just too bad okay well then
too bad why should I advocate for anyone
spending money on Twitter if we are not
going to actually have free speech Viva
fry actually pointed out if Elon does
not reinstate him then do not expect
anything different than what we saw with
ajayagar and Prague agrawal and he says
too bad all right
let's talk about it now the Democrats
want an FTC investigation so the whole
thing is just it's insane I gotta I
gotta say I don't understand why Twitter
has garnered this much attention except
for the fact that's probably used by
intelligence agencies to manipulate the
American public
so we're gonna get into all that but
before we do my friends head over to
establishedtitles.com and you can become
a Scottish Laird or Lord if you're
speaking colloquial american English
basically you can buy a small plot of
land in Scotland and then if you're a
landowner there you're a uh a lord
they say it's a Project based on a
historic Scottish custom where
landowners are referred to Lords and
Ladies their title packs give you at
least one square foot of dedicated land
with a unique plot number on a private
estate in edelston Scotland and an
official certificate with a Crest to
head to that they're also they're also a
fun and novel way to preserve the
natural Woodlands of Scotland while
helping Global reforestation efforts
they do this by planting a tree with
every order and work with global
Charities like one tree planted and
trees for the future the first 200
people perching the title pack using my
link will effectively be next to my plot
that's established titles.com
timcastirl within a few minutes walking
distance it will be it makes for an
amusing an amazing last minute gift and
you can use the promo code timcast IRL
or go to established titles.com
timcastirl and last night because we're
a silly Bunch we were joking about
people ordering this using the name
ligma Johnson and uh that would be a
great gift as well but then we kind of
realized it'd be hilarious if 50 000
people buy lot of square foot of land in
Scotland you'd have 50 000 square feet
square of land owned by Lord ligma
Johnson so consider that I guess I
wonder if they're gonna get mad at me
for saying that in the promo spot but
whatever I mean it'll be funny I kind of
want to buy a ligma Johnson plot of land
and get a lord ligma Johnson so uh
thanks established titles for sponsoring
the show everyone was really excited
some I think someone super chatted
saying they were going to do that and we
started talking about it so
established titles.com timcast IRL but
don't forget head over to timcast.com
become a member to help support our work
directly we're working on a bunch of
cultural Endeavors we may be um working
on a movie it seems like we will be
working on a movie production and uh we
don't have everything we don't want
everything to be overtly political but
we are growing as fast as we can I know
I've said before that we want to we want
to be similar to The Daily wire in that
regard we want to produce cultural shows
music and things like that but we are a
fraction of the size of the daily wire
so all we can do is just work slowly and
make our way up before we get started
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and all and so much more is Aiden
Paladin hey great to be here uh who are
you oh uh hi I'm Aiden Paladin I mostly
discuss uh social science and the
intersection of social science and
politics here on YouTube it was a PhD
student but I decided I liked doing this
better yeah thanks for having me and I
and uh we start I I hit you up because
you were posting about I mean this is
going to sound cliche and tribal but a
series of studies showing that many on
the left prefer are driven by Envy
hatred violence greed Etc yeah I was
actually really shocked because we you
hear that kind of rhetoric all the time
on the Right End from the left towards
the right that of the other side of
course you know dichotomistic
partisanship of the other people they
must just be evil
but what I found when I looked into the
data was more or less that I what is
evil I guess you can be defined by
whoever is defining evil
but the greed and the anger and the
hatred and more than anything the Envy
it's just they're so consistently
envious
everybody listening is like yeah I know
yeah well so pretty much all of social
sciences no duh and it is all NoDa but
you need to go find the data and
actually be able to illustrate it with
science we'll talk about it especially
as it pertains to censorship we also
have Hannah Claire brimelow hi I'm
Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com that's right yeah well all
right and Luke's here I want to thank
everyone in the comment section for the
Laquisha comments they mean a lot to me
I appreciate them very much and even
though Elon Musk could censor your
speech he cannot censor shirts on the
best politicalshirts.com that's why I
created the website today I'm wearing a
shirt about the crazy immune system
deniers out there who are very dangerous
to your health and if you want to warn
everyone in the general public you could
get the shirt on again the best
politicalshirts.com or
bidenfetterman.com whichever one you
choose
and I'm search.com as always guys all
right ladies and gentlemen here's the
here's the big story Elon Musk tweeted
reinstate former president Trump yes no
well as you can see I voted yes of
course and there's just about 800 000
votes in uh what are we looking at like
20 minutes just as shy of 20 minutes
62 percent say yes 38 30 say no and uh I
kind of I find it kind of silly like why
is a former president whether he's
allowed to speak in the public Town
Square being brought up to just like a
poll from the CEO is kind of a weird
thing it seems very strange especially
given this is supposed to be how Twitter
operates going forward like do we get to
vote on everyone from now on I would
probably use Twitter if this was the
Democratic process
well unfortunately then you can have
very likely to invoke mob roll kind of
stuff uh marble consensus of people can
then just get together and it's just the
way that anything Works in terms of
banning people from other sites you get
a group of people together you incite
them into saying oh we need to mass
report demand the Twitter remove this
person or vice versa demand that they
reinstate somebody so
democratizing Twitter can be potentially
harmful in its own way who the hell
would have thought that the former
president of the United States who's
running to be the next president of the
United States is is is having his future
of his speech being determined by by
freaking Twitter poll that absolutely
makes no sense at all it's absolutely
ridiculous and it it really shows you
how Elon Musk is really failing here
he's not doing a good job he should make
a strong decision he should make a
decision that is based on principles not
on Mob Rule and that's essentially what
he's depending on here which is
ridiculous I think Elon is this strange
character because we especially
conservatives want to Rally around him
he says interesting things things that
we feel like are right but also he
doesn't operate a hundred percent by
conservative values and he doesn't hide
it right like Tesla is the from what I
understand the only car company that
operates without a state-owned partner
in China why is that why is he permitted
that right it's just one of these things
you mean like he operates in China and
he's not being controlled by the state
or whatever yeah so if
saying all car companies in the U.S work
with China so all car companies if you
want to manufacture in China again I'm
not an expert but this is what I've been
reading about it
um they have a partner to help them with
their distribution and Manufacturing
China Tesla is the only car company that
operates without this kind of
partnership the car companies in China
are owned by the Chinese government why
is Tesla allowed to do this I I think
Elon Musk is a really interesting
character but I am not surprised that
he's not always consistent right we like
Free Speech but also we have a poll for
the president like that seems strange
yeah I think he saw that he could make
money from this
I think that's really it I think he
likes the Babylon bee I think he saw an
opportunity to make money because
it seems clear when you're active on
Twitter that the majority of people want
jokes want to have fun but you can't and
what was happening is slowly over time
Twitter was being compressed into a
really boring and awful space and it was
resulting in I mean here's what I think
elon's like why are there so many
competitors to Twitter emerging why is
Twitter losing so many customers
and it's because they're censoring
everybody he probably thought you know
I'll buy it uncensor some of the people
and then you know we'll make we'll we'll
make it more valuable and then we'll
turn it public again that's what he said
he was going to do so of course he's
saying [ __ ] he's doing a poll to
reinstate Trump why because he wants to
see what people on Twitter actually
think and if and it's kind of smart
we're up to 932 000 votes 62 say yes and
that's probably where it's going to be
because if he's like the overwhelming
majority of people want him on the
platform then I'm going to service the
customers
still weak absolutely weak I don't know
what's going on with the audio is the
audio okay or is it fine what's going on
I feel like it's fine I don't know if
it's something it's exactly the same as
was when I started so I don't know yeah
but okay but anyway it's still weak it's
still extremely disappointing you you
make a decision if you're going to be
standing by free speech that means
standing by that decision and nothing
else again I don't know do you have the
audio fixed yeah okay you keep talking
and I'm just I'm distracted with all of
them
uh yeah that's always muted everything's
fine yeah I don't know okay that's all I
had to say I just feel like Elon Musk
knows that he's ultimately
um trading in public popularity right so
it I don't actually know and he could be
a devout Free Speech purist he loves it
but he recognizes that in modern
application it has to be limited in some
capacity I don't really know what his
philosophy on this is I just know that
he's inconsistent in a lot of ways and I
as much as I want to admire the things
that he's done that are good I feel like
we all have to take it with a grain of
salt and remember that like he is
ultimately
serving himself as far as we know we
don't know what the end of that is I
think he's running it like a CEO like
he's run everything else so ultimately
the way he's looking at Twitter is
what's going to be most profitable if he
ends up getting a huge mass of people
who actually do leave Twitter and manage
to force themselves away from it because
Donald Trump is back on there sending
out mean tweets or because Alex Jones is
out there existing then maybe that's why
he's decided against that unilaterally
well because it's clearly about the
money so he did now oh yeah
you want to read it Hannah
hi there I'm sorry you don't even know
my name Luke I've known you for so long
I said Hannah I think you have to read
it that's not like no no yes it is sorry
you haven't addressed me correct Hannah
and then I was like Claire I said box
popular Vox day
Elon Musk
have they figured out the Bots have they
figured out the fake accounts on on this
particular platform because again that
was a major topic of discussion with
Elon Musk previously talking about how
many people were gaming the system
manipulating this this this big Tech
social media platform to the point where
of course a lot of this stuff was
illegitimate so how how do we know that
this this poll is actually going to be
legitimate how do we know that other
systems other people other groups won't
be gaming this Poll for their own
personal benefit uh which still hasn't
been cleared up to how many accounts are
real how many accounts are fake how is
this platform being used for the
Sinister purposes of a lot of powerful
people that's a question that I think a
lot of people are still waiting to be
answered that might never be answered
because we're still waiting to find out
what's going on here and if if Elon Musk
is just taking this approach just to
make money it's not going to be
incentivized for him to be honest with
the people about how many people are
fake on the platform nope and I would
say that's what is Twitter blue doing
nothing but you know putting certain
people forward it's just being a little
bit more honest about it than Twitter's
been in the past that it's what you're
going to see because you pay us for it
and there are people who are so addicted
to Twitter that they will I think
probably stay there and keep doing at
least for the time being they they
created this this rumor last night that
Twitter was going to shut down and it's
very clever organizing on the part of
the left basically the idea is make
people fear they're going to lose their
follower their follower ships or
whatever and then you'll get them to
leave the platform and so they do
they say oh no no Twitter's going to
shut down by tomorrow quick and then
everyone says everyone quick follow me
on Mastodon and they're trying to create
a a surge a tsunami an inflection point
where enough people jump ship that
they'll actually start using the other
platform I wouldn't suggest Mastodon for
people on the left it's totally uh you
know unfederated or de-federated so
there's no moderating on Mastodon people
can use very naughty nasty words that
you certainly couldn't use on Twitter
you can't you can't censor them or
whatever
they ban anything that's illegal in
Germany apparently uh I know that when
there was a big Twitter surge or you
know they were all these hashtags moved
them or like Twitter Exodus a couple
weeks ago and then immediately they
moved to Macedon and couldn't believe
all the
racial slurs and anti-Semitism and then
they were like oh no my safe space so um
and it was really funny but that's about
it I mean that's the reality of a
decentralized network they're not going
to have the resources of a major
corporation so this is what you get
I don't know I just don't trust Twitter
I never trusted it before I don't trust
it now that elon's there I know that
it's sort of a a personality thing some
people live or die but I really feel
like in some ways like I'm on it
professionally to get news releases as
they come out because so many people
have converted it into this you know
tool for the pr
um but I don't I don't trust Elon Musk
like if this is how we decide who gets
to be on Twitter I don't want to be
there anyways right if it's like if you
were concerned about double verification
like
verifying anybody who pays money is the
stupidest idea maybe he thought people
wanted it so bad that he was going to
make a ton of money right away from it I
feel like this whole rollout has been
just really really bad like Elon you
either go for it or you don't there's no
half measures you think I'm gonna pay
eight bucks like I'm I'm inclined to
actually cancel the so we signed up
timcast news for Twitter blue for the
verification for the most part and
because it's a new account and we wanted
to have access to like filters or
whatever and also I want I want Twitter
to succeed I want I want it to work with
what Elon is doing I want to believe
that when you know when he reinstate
some of these people we saw last week
some people got reinstated all right all
that's really good and then he and then
he and then he he comes out and he's
just like I don't know with all this
stuff basically I'm I'm kind of just
okay
all right now I'm not entirely convinced
we're going to see this this platform
get fixed so here's here's my mindset
now
I'm not I'm not rooting against Elon on
this stuff I'm I'm looking forward to
some improvements but uh I'm gonna lean
back a little bit you know I was I was I
was leaning back last week or two weeks
ago then we heard last week that he had
reinstated some accounts and I was like
okay so it looks like he is going to
start improving things and I said okay
you know I'll get Twitter blue but I'll
get it only for Tim guesters I'm not
gonna buy for my personal just yet we'll
see what happens
now we have this and I'm kind of like
do you think Elon could have done more
with a uh secondary platform like if he
had taken over not truths necessarily
but like some other things this is the
one thing that Ian is very very wrong
about all the time freeing the code
Twitter's code is garbage it's nothing
their algorithm sure I guess I agree
with Ian insofar as free the code so
that we can know what the algorithm is
doing to us because it's manipulating us
but gab parlor getter Minds The the
ability to input text and have a server
output it to a person who decides to
follow a number like
not hard to do yeah so what Elon bought
was you and me and Luke and Aiden and
serge he bought all of you at home who
use the platform it's a community of
people having control over that is
useful how do you you if you launch a
new Twitter how do you get people to use
it you can't because what makes Twitter
valuable is that people are there it is
downtown
so you can buy a little store in the
suburbs I guess getting people to show
up there's gonna be a lot harder so this
is what Elon really wanted I don't think
you know it could have been better or
worse the problem is you can't have it
both ways let me pull up this tweet here
Elon Musk tweeted what should Twitter do
next
original good name says bring back Alex
Jones Elon Musk says no
the Hodge twins tweeted should Elon
bring back Alex Jones of 140 000 votes
57.7 say yes 42.3 say no
and uh then we have this tweet from viva
fry who makes the perfect Point Alex
Jones is the litmus test Elon Musk not
just on the issue of freedom of speech
but on the issue of not bending the knee
to political and judicial intimidation
if this is a hard no your Twitter will
never be any more trustworthy than parag
or Jack's Twitter
and Elon responded too bad
there you go
what a prick seriously if you're gonna
do something like this violate free
speech for an individual that is
controversial while allowing other
controversial voices to be on there if
you're if you're allowing Kathy Griffin
to be on there but not Alex Jones at
least explain yourself and what what did
Alex Jones do
well he yelled at Allah for darzi yeah
he was in he was in one of the
Congressional confronted Jack Dorsey
while he confronted his Banning was over
Oliver Darcy he put up a video where he
was calling him a rat face or something
yeah I'm not a fan of that right I can't
stand this stuff there's a lot of people
who just laugh and say no they deserve
it Alex was right and it's like I don't
care you're allowed to like that fine
it's free speech and all that but I
don't like it and I certainly don't
think he should have been banned for
doing it if you're in public and
someone's mad at you and they confront
you there was no security threat or
anything like that it was just Alex
yelling at the guy they banned him for
it Kathy Griffin held up an image of a
severed head and she didn't even get
banned for that she got like a slap on
the wrist she got banned because she
mocked Elon Musk parroting his account
without putting parity trying to I guess
make a point or whatever he reinstates
her but showing holding up a severed
head of the president that was never in
question she also evaded the ban and
then went on her Dead Mother's platform
in order to still raise her voice
against Elon Musk so again something's
happening here you're going to allow her
to have a voice but not not Alex Jones
explain your reasoning don't be a prick
don't just say too bad what's going on
here is there internal pressure are
there people inside of the company that
are saying no don't do this are there
corporations are there government
agencies are there any other
institutions that are pressuring you to
do this at least explain yourself if
you're going to be making this kind of
statement and Alex Jones of course
responded making his own video uh
regarding this specific news and he says
Hey guys don't blame Elon Musk here he's
Alex Jones is trying to be the bigger
person here uh addressing this larger
Saga here but but at the end of the day
we at least deserve an explanation
because we were promised Free Speech
this is not free speech this is a person
deciding what he wants with his own
whims that that shouldn't be acceptable
to anyone yeah I was going to say Alex
Jones doesn't have a choice but to be
the bigger person right if he goes on a
tirade and is mad at Elon he's like well
your family's not even that cool like he
could be like Kathy Griffin and go
nuclear and go crazy but it's okay if
she does it exactly she's a really funny
comedian you don't understand hilarious
hilarious it's the same thing with now
the 230 ruling though right of that
maybe you could make the argument that
Elon is worried that you know Alex comes
back and because he's being sued for
three trillion dollars now which is I
believe it is three trillion three
trillion which is just a little bit
under twice is it really 3 trillion yes
just a little under twice the annual DOD
uh uh I think it's three times the GDP
of France is something like that isn't
it sir I just looked up today that it's
twice the dod's annual budget so yeah
three trillion dollars is on the table
they're trying to fund the war in
Ukraine the money's got to come from
somewhere but so maybe you could make
the argument that before this decision
comes down about section 230 is that
maybe Elon is worried that well if you
know they're going after Alex Jones for
for the GDP of France that then they'll
come after him in some way but if
section 230 is no longer going to apply
to make it so that you can sue the uh
platform for what someone on it says
then it doesn't make any sense people
are are bringing up that Alex Jones
issued a statement saying Elon shouldn't
bring him back he's the most
controversial person and elon's going up
against everybody and so he's got to do
what he can and uh I don't care Alex I
understand what you're saying and
I get it but uh either Elon is going to
there's a couple ways he could play this
he could just not respond he could say
nothing he is choosing to come out and
outright say you know that free speech
thing I tweeted about an hour ago screw
that I don't really care so that's what
pisses me off I totally get that elon's
like dude there's only so much I can do
totally get it I respect it he just
bought this massive platform and needs
to survive it needs money to operate he
doesn't want it to die he doesn't want
to lose money on that and he wants to
actually bring Free Speech back I get it
you bring back Alex Jones they go
nuclear against you and then the whole
thing implodes he brought back Andrew
Tate Andrew Tate is back on the platform
yeah so so how will we picking and
choosing here yes what's the scale here
well the scale is Alex points out he's
the most controversial person in the
world that being said Elon did not have
to come out and insult Alex's fans like
that he could have just ignored it yeah
he didn't have to respond to anyone
tweeting on Alex's behalf too I mean he
is looking for this fight but to me I
just don't understand why like what
purpose is this serving for The Virtue
signaling I guess but he's purchasing
the advertisers so he can be like look
see I said I wouldn't bring him back but
because when he said he hadn't made a
decision on Trump or when he said he
wasn't going to bring back Jones a bunch
of leftists were like at least there's I
saw high profile leftists journalists
saying at least some sanity and things
like that he's getting positive feedback
from that which is the first positive
feedback he's gotten on any of this
however it is a slippery slope and it's
the same way they've Fallen before
versus Alex Jones and then who who else
is then not acceptable but that's not
true he's getting attacked by the
corporate media insanely every year
there's a piece after hippies after he
peace this is not being met with like
okay this is great this is being ignored
and they're still trying to attack him
any way that they possibly can so why
are you trying to placate these people
right is he like trying to go over to
the FBI or BlackRock or China being like
look at me I'm a totalitarian I'm a
prick too I could do what you guys do is
that what you're doing because what else
are we left to speculate here because
otherwise there's no other rational
conclusion than him as you Tim mentioned
specifically showing off to the powers
that be saying I could play ball I could
play game uh you know just tell me what
to do and I'll follow those orders and
that's not a platform that I believe in
that's not a platform that I want to be
on I want to read the Super Chat from
old stick key taint he says voting for
Trump's unbanning is a smart move Force
the advertisers to justify why they want
to uh what do you say pause
advertisement poll advertisements when
the majority of their target audience
wants him on actually yeah that's a
really great Point what out what what
Elon needs to say to the advertisers is
you're being attacked by activists who
are lying to you and costing you money
once we get rid of those Bots you will
be able to actually Target your audience
who like people like Jones or Trump
that's probably uh probably the move
he's making in that regard they'd have
to publish or at least actually conduct
some real internal research that they
could show to their shareholders on that
and the people they're selling
advertising space there's no
shareholders or not shareholders sorry
uh selling marketing well I think
there's I think they do have technically
stockholders or right because because
they're there he does have people who
are holding privately
advertisements to then they would want
to be able to tell them that look that
your advertisements are being shown to
real people and that those people when
they are given internal when they're
given polls because you know you can
take these exit polls on Twitter sure
they send you an email and you say would
you like to take this poll about your
experience with Twitter oh you get
Twitter blue for a month for free or
something like that so you can try it
out if you finish our survey there's all
kinds of ways to incentivize people to
give you data that you could use and
then take that and say hair to the
advertisers people say they want Trump
to this certain degree and actually have
something to to sell to them and say
it's not all Bots I tried advertising on
Twitter because I I he they're giving
the double verification everybody so I
tweeted hey Elon how much do I got to
spend to get the official tag and uh and
I don't expect him actually respond to
me but so I decided to take out an ad on
our uh Trump going Super Saiyan shirt
which is available in the chat and it's
the super Maga shirt and uh so I was
gonna put a big campaign bind it 25k to
see if if it's legit and because again I
I do want to see Twitter succeed I'm not
just throwing money at Elon it's
advertising a product we sell that we
make money on that I bet if I spend this
money we're going to make more money
back they rejected it they said a
cartoon image of Donald Trump going
Super Saiyan was political
why
now now that now I'm deeply offended I
just wanted to sell a t-shirt of Donald
Trump with Goku here you can't even do
that apparently
go ahead sorry oh no that was it that
was just a green how do they determine
what's political because I've only used
the promotion feature once on YouTube
and it was or not YouTube on Twitter and
it was to promote a YouTube video that
was not largely political but it was
there were politics involved in the
video so how did they determine what's
political it's Trump yeah they didn't
want a a cartoon of trump that makes him
look good they don't want to take the
money for that or something well my
video was an hour long and it was
political at some points but they I
guess didn't want to watch an hour long
video to figure that part out the image
isn't even Pro or anti-trump it's just
meant to be silly it's Trump with you
know spiky blonde hair
now there's a couple things to consider
especially with this poll with uh Elon
Musk asking if Donald Trump should be
reinstated or not because uh on October
3rd Mashable has this article that I
think is is worth revisiting right now
that's titled in Elon musk's words it
seems Twitter Bots are always to blame
now there hasn't been any kind of
Reckoning with the Bots there hasn't
been any kind of Discovery there haven't
been any kind of major Bombshells
surrounding the bots on big Tech social
media platforms especially Twitter but
Elon Musk was complaining about the Bots
after he did a poll on his own Twitter
account specifically on October 3rd
asking if there should be a Ukrainian
Russian peace deal after their response
he specifically said this is the biggest
bot attack I've ever seen so why after
not dealing with the Bots are we
deciding if the former president of the
United States who's running to be
president of 2024 will be able to have
any kind of speech also if you remember
he also tweeted earlier today that he
believes in the policy of freedom of
speech no he doesn't it but he says he
does but he doesn't believe in the
freedom of reach and he says negative
content is going to be de-boosted
demonetized what's negative content what
who's going to be determining what's
negative what's positive again
everything here is arbitrary there's no
baselines there's no rules he's
following along and doing horrible
things like not allowing free speech on
the platform which he promised which
everyone now feels backstabbed about and
that's that idiom that you see people on
the left use so commonly of oh freedom
of speech doesn't mean freedom from
consequences so it's basically coming
down to the same kind of thing I feel
like at this point everyone should just
tweet at Elon Musk like get it give us a
timeline on the bot situation like
didn't Ann Coulter have like a countdown
every day that Donald Trump didn't like
do something about the wall like where
is our like the Bots are gone countdown
because it I mean to both of your points
Elon Musk is putting out polls and then
saying they're being hacked by bot so
you already told us this problem and
also how are you supposed to give
accurate data to any advertisers if
they're always being if you can say at
any time oh well the Bots got to this I
mean you would think that ideally if he
is working in true capitalism and he
wants to make as much money as possible
he would be hounding his staff to deal
with the Bots or are the Bots a problem
that can't be solved that's why I asked
earlier like do you think he made a
mistake buying Twitter like is this
platform and I'm not a tech person but
is it so corrupted the Bots are
something that can't be removed at this
point you can't purge them fast enough
at this point would it be better to
abandon ship and move on to something
else even though you can't bring the
people with you a complete user
verification would do something maybe to
help with them but he's not doing that
but he's not gonna do and and also I I
think that you're going to lose a lot of
people will leave the platform if you
require someone to although you need to
have a phone number you don't need to
force everyone it's if you want
verification you got to use a real
picture a real name so we verified you I
thought when he was talking about a
verification he was going to verify
everyone the same way we have to be
verified either a brand account that
confirms they are the corporation and
it's really hard to do some I I don't
know if uh Twitter does it this way but
you have to like send him a photo of
your Articles of Incorporation with like
your ID showing that you are the officer
because they're verifying you
for everyone else you can use different
photos and stuff but typically you have
to be the person you're verified to be
milianopolis lost his verification
because he included in his bio BuzzFeed
journalist or something like that they
said up but you're impersonating
verification removed so Elon comes in
and he's like you can have a badge you
want it so bad for eight dollars and
then he just verifies everyone then when
that implodes he's like I'll just give a
second verification to Big Brands and
that's what my point was okay what
constitutes worthiness for getting
verified twice
I know it's confusing and it's weird
being on the platform seeing double
verification only the corporate media
which again Elon knows Elon knows the
corporate media runs scams if we're
going to be fighting this information if
we're going to be getting rid of Contra
controversial figures that spread
disinformation CNN needs to be gone from
the platform immediately MSNBC needs to
be gone from the platform immediately
and and they're not so if we're going to
not allow Alex Jones for you know
allegedly being misinformation he got
something's wrong obviously we could
criticize everyone I've criticized them
before but at the end of the day you you
take his record and you take it to the
corporate media he has told far more
truths than of course the corporate
media that's routinely lying to the
American people and running larger
psyopsis against them well I can at
least say I'm satisfied seeing stuff
like this from Engadget Democratic
senators ask FTC to investigate Elon
Musk over his handling of Twitter
what the lawmakers cite the botched
rollout of paid verification and the
recent departures of top privacy execs
on what grounds does that constitute an
FTC investigation he fired people
seriously and the Democrats are now this
is what corruption looks like well now
it's the Public Square it wasn't before
it's a private company they can do what
they want but now we have an issue that
the FTC needs to get involved with
that's right for years Twitter has been
wreaking havoc on our political sphere
on the public and uh nobody would do
anything about it I mean there were some
Republicans that have hearings and
they'd waste everyone's time now the
Democrats are shocked and concerned
about what's going on it's just it's all
so fake I'm done with it it's fake
you're Liars I don't care to listen to
you we are wasting our time being
bothered by even playing a game with
these people so I think the one thing
you can do right now is improve yourself
start a family have kids buy property
improve on your skills get in shape you
want to succeed and you want to win this
get fit Eat Right cut out the sugars
have a family make money that was my
favorite thing that Elon said on Twitter
like a little while ago when it came out
that he had like secret twins he was
like I have a big family and I hope you
all do too and I was like yeah okay yeah
he was saying most billionaires don't
have kids it's great but I'm saying if
you if if you think you're past path to
Victory let's say you're really good at
playing Monopoly and so you're like if I
enter this Monopoly tournament then I'll
win the grand prize only problem is you
realize that your opponent isn't playing
fairly and so you keep just playing the
game even though they're lying about
everything that's going on eventually
he's got to say maybe I should find
another way to succeed if everybody just
focuses on themselves and ignores this
obvious corruption and hypocrisy I'm not
saying don't resist it don't fight
against it I'm saying stop asking them
politely to please stop stop treating
them like they're doing this on accident
that's my Point improve yourself assume
everything they're doing is intentional
and designed to hurt you and then figure
out ways to overcome notably right now
we've got it we've got to overcome the
ballot harvesting operations they have
Scott Pressler says he's going to do it
I got faith he can let's see what we can
do to help back him and many others who
are going to start working for the 2020
on the 24 2024 election and then maybe
we can get some people in who will just
do away with this stuff
yeah people have to do something the
only one who did anything about the you
know fortification was DeSantis and well
that went how it went yeah
descendants 2024. he's the only one who
did anything everyone else complained
about it and then did nothing he made
some very interesting comments against
the world economic Forum uh today which
I thought was also kind of very
eye-opening because very few politicians
usually talked about these larger key
issues that do affect them uh but but
again with this news of this Democratic
senator asking the FTC to investigate
someone it's been seven days since FTX
went bankrupt seven days obviously
criminal fraud here obviously people
have been defrauded people have been
robbed of their money no one got
arrested Madoff got arrested in 24 hours
after his Ponzi scheme was was exposed
to everyone seven days later and then we
have the FBI warning the guy that
they're going to maybe maybe possibly be
going after him are you kidding me this
reeks of corruption and this could be
one of the reasons why Elon Musk is like
oh crap the the FTC might be on my butt
I gotta do what they want me to do as
the federal government is telling big
Tech social media platforms to ban
particular voices again the US
government is violating the first
amendment in more ways than one
particularly when it comes to online
speech this could be one of the reasons
why we don't have free speech and we
won't have free speech on Twitter as
announced by Elon Musk today
I think that that's probably very likely
that there's some well with this thing
about the the FTC involvement that the
federal government might have gotten in
contact with them
yeah there isn't that over the FTX
Scandal well they keep threatening him
on Twitter right and so maybe he's just
like I gotta tone things down I just
think it's crazy we can like threaten
Elon Musk FDX there's nothing but Taylor
Swift's uh General ticket sale gets
canceled and there's already a doj
investigation into Anti-Trust and
Ticketmaster they were charging like 20
000 a ticket or something oh it's crazy
it is a like wild west in the case
you're buying it I have six tickets I
Will Bradley announce that what what how
but you didn't so I'm a millionaire
thanks Krypton I'm just kidding
um I the whole process was insane and
you have to like register beforehand to
become a verified fan they'll decide if
you're a verified fan if you are a
verified fan you get a code it's texted
to you this sounds like a cult yeah
are you okay I don't I don't know Hannah
Lou I'm not sure who Hannah is but like
the process was insane and the big thing
was uh I'm really sorry about this Tim I
actually bought my tickets while it was
live on pop culture on Tuesday because
of the content well yeah and the ticket
sales got delayed for so long that I
like carried my laptop up and I was like
look Brett and Mary like I'm here for
you I do this every Tuesday but I have
to get these tickets it's now or never
did the tickets come with Kool-Aid not
that I know of but maybe at the concert
she'll like inject us all I'm not sure I
just feel like as uh as a millennial
where is the concert she has a bunch she
has 52 shows how much were the tickets
uh mine were two hundred and forty
dollars okay are you gonna resell them
no well I have I have people who I
bought them for Ticketmaster said that
they gave out about 1.5 million of these
codes put 2 million people on the wait
list and then they were expecting
30 percent of people who got codes to
use them and of those people like each
buy three tickets okay I don't know
where these mem these numbers hold on
hold on right so I heard it was reported
that some of the tickets are 20 grand
yeah so okay people are only selling
them you've got tickets for some people
do you think those people would be
happier to watch Taylor Swift or get 20
grand I honestly think they'd rather
watch Taylor Swift but I'll ask oh come
on we could phone a friend right now
I'll let them know the Kool-Aid is
strong you don't understand like there
is such a like I think it's twofold I
think people really like Taylor Swift
she hasn't been on tour in a while but
the other thing is like I all of my
friends who want to go to this concert
were like robbed of two years of their
20s for because of covid like they want
to go out they want to do things it's
gonna see Taylor Swift look man you
weren't indoctrinated the way I was in
doctor we're judging you very heavily
I'm okay with that
what did you have to do to prove that
you were a Taylor Swift I have no idea
oh of 15 different people because you've
rebought them no I bought them I got a
code I don't know why I was selected
other than they wanted to like see my
heart rate go up I'm not sure uh but it
was it was this insane process
Ticketmaster crash AOC tweeted during
this pre-sale as everyone was
complaining about it uh they're a trust
we should break Ticketmaster up because
they had oh yeah well yeah but that's
just because she couldn't get her that's
what I thought I was like this girl
wants to go to the concert I have one
more AOC if you'd like to come with me
uh no but it's it's this crazy thing
where we have this pop star returning to
tour after kovid and by Friday after
this disastrous uh sale
there's already an antitrust
investigation like oh I know it's
amazing why are they moving this quickly
Amy klobuchar's granddaughter wants to
go to Taylor Swift yeah didn't get
tickets and she's like bring the doj in
like it's the second anything in any way
negatively affects hold on the those in
the oligarchy then all of a sudden they
they put their feet to the fire and they
care
how old is Taylor Swift she's 32. so
she's she's not going to be old enough
in 2024 is she
no no oh wait
oh she is gonna be old enough Taylor
Swift she's uh got an idea for you her
birthday is uh uh
December 13th meaning that by the time
she would be inaugurated she would be 35
years old Taylor Swift is going to run
for the Democratic ticket that's it
that's what they're doing that's why AOC
is all over it yeah I think that makes
sense I mean I think she is that
influential among at least young voters
no way maybe I'm wrong what yeah maybe
I'm wrong maybe she's gonna be 34.
she'll be 34 I think
wait wait she's about to turn 33.
so that means she'll be 34 in in 2023
yeah she'll be 35 at the end of 20 uh
2024. so that means she can run because
by the time she's going to be sworn in
she will be old enough to be uh
president 35 right I would do anything
to see a trump Taylor Swift debate oh
man I will sell tickets to that
Ticketmaster can crash okay I'd buy
those ones though like a trump Kanye
ticket versus like a swift Obama Swift
AOC Trump Kanye Swift Ocasio we're going
a little bit dangerously into idiocracy
here though yeah but at this point I'm
like you know I feel like we're down
we're going on a water slide and like
the only way to get through it is just
just to roll through it you know what I
mean I mean Taylor Swift presidency I
just can't imagine IQs are dropping so
anything's anything's possible the thing
is she's a figurehead she is the pop the
pop star of an entire generation and to
so many people who were raised
especially in the social media era she
has more influence than any politician I
mean AOC has whatever amount of
followers online she has also kind of
translated herself into an internet
presence but really there are certain
people who who capture attention and
whether you like it or not Taylor Swift
is one of them and I respect that she's
not everyone's thing I myself don't like
a lot of her music but I feel compelled
like I have to go to this concert think
about like just you know from for a
moment bear with me how cool would it be
if like Taylor Swift runs and then she
becomes like the most brutal dictator
ever it's just like extraditional
extrajudicial assassinations are through
the roof tenfold what they were under
Obama and then it's like you have like a
documentary 50 50 years from now
president Swift was the most aggressive
authoritarian leader Any Nation had ever
seen this way yeah she's like throw the
bombs
running out of the campaign slogan Shake
It Off
the IQ deficit thing is really
fascinating which um because children
that were born under the during the
pandemic during the lockdowns which
again just being the first time people
can get out one study found that they
have a 30-point IQ deficit using 30
points yes
um early for for infant uh IQ tests
which those are not super valid but if
that maintains in in the early studies
of 30 point IQ deficit that would mean
that the average person born in that
three-year period would have an average
IQ of 70 and remember average means the
middle
meaning the other half is lower than
that
horrifying it's like that George Carlin
joke he was like think about how stupid
the average person is now realize half
of them are stupider than that yeah wow
well uh I feel bad for these kids but I
mostly feel bad for myself because by
the time I'm you know in my 50s and
desperately trying to vote to save this
country or Planet you're gonna have a
lot a lot of really dumb people voting
they're going to be like masks are good
I used to wear masks all the time
I vote for masks and it's like a mess I
think it's mandatory masking when you're
going to the bathroom they're gonna be
like I don't feel comfortable without my
mask
yeah but it's going to be like they're
not gonna say that because their IQs are
very low they're going to be walking
into a room and someone's gonna be like
you gotta take the mask off and they go
I need the mask and they go sir take the
mask off relief and then go
and then they're like okay okay okay
okay you can wear the mask jeez as
they're sucking down on their watermelon
Peach Vapes
I could just see it now watermelon Peach
is that like the flavor that you I just
made something up and as I was talking
sounds pretty it's his personal favorite
toast flavor or something I used to
avocado that was flavored babe sounds
horrific and Taylor Swift is giving them
out of her campaign yeah yeah there you
go it's like the young people speaking
of low IQs let's pull up this story New
York City lawyer sobs in court as she
sentenced to 15 months behind bars for
fire bombing NYPD van with Molotov
cocktail fashioned out of a Bud Light
bottle during BLM protests urugu Ramen
asked the judge to spare her prison time
and give her a second chance to redeem
herself for what she called a momentary
lapse of judgment yo lady
prison is for dangerous people okay 15
months you're getting a slap on the
wrist considering you you you fire
bombed a car if it was like she threw a
rock and it hit somebody in the head I
might be like okay you know 15 months
don't throw rocks people come on no she
threw a fire bomb she like was handing
them out to people so uh you know again
speaking of low IQs we're already seeing
uh we're already seeing how bad it can
be when these people have momentary
lapses of judgment the scary thing about
it is that people like like her they
think they're smart that's a scary thing
a midwitism
well you know midnight midwives are
average you know like midwoods are
slightly above average but they're very
convinced that they're usually part of
when people get called midwits it's that
they are also part of that convinced
that they are very intelligent which
makes it dangerous midwit is basically
they are a little smart like a little
bit above average but but they're not
smart enough to truly understand so
they're active players like these
journalists the the corporate press
they're midwits
you know there's that IQ bell curve you
see all the time where the dumb guy and
the smart guy agree on things and the
average person is like doing the wrong
thing pro-establishment or whatever
this is kind of scary when you when when
you think about it and then you realize
that we're going to have a wave of
substantially stupider people due to the
masking policies and the lockdown
policies in these schools these kids are
all developmentally stunted and they're
not getting they're not getting those
years back I don't know if you guys ever
read about the the girl Raised by Wolves
I mean not the girl but there's a bunch
of stories of like kids they never learn
you know by the time they're adults
there was like some story I read about a
woman who was uh like seriously abused
and locked in a basement until she was
13. it was like Trixie or something like
that when she was when she was finally
rescued she couldn't learn to speak
proper colloquial English she could only
say certain words like hungry sleep but
she couldn't actually articulate long
Thoughts with other people that's scary
man those uh foundational developmental
years are really really important
um for children to become adults or to
be able to function whatsoever in
society so yeah a child can survive in
the woods being raised by wolves you can
survive but you can't you're going to
have so many developmental issues so
with these children who have grown up
never seen their parents face or very
rarely seen their parents face which is
a huge part of it of forming the
connection between mother and child and
father and child they don't have any of
that so that does explain partially why
the IQ deficit is what we're seeing in
the preliminary data you ever see that
study where they had the mom they
brought in a bunch of moms with kids and
then the mom would not respond to the
baby's facial cues have you seen that
it's so sad the baby like tries to get
the mom to react and they like they told
the mother just remains stone-faced and
do not respond to the baby and then a
veg the baby starts crying like freaking
out yeah these immune system deniers are
absolutely sick and disgusting I'm
serious when we look at the policies
that they've implemented they knew the
horrors that this was going to bring and
we've seen video after video of these
fat bureaucratic totalitarian teachers
just shove a mask on a child's face as
they're literally fighting with them
toddler small children in kindergarten
were forced to be masked which is
leading to severe
development developmental issues that
we're going to be seeing the long-term
consequences of especially in the future
there was even major politicians that
came out and said I guys I made a
mistake you did of course you did we all
knew you you did we were talking about
this we were warning about this and our
voices were censored by big Tech social
media and this is why it went on for so
long it was because of that censorship
it's because people couldn't push back
it's because the ideas couldn't be
challenged or tested in the public
sphere and we were censored and we had
to continue with this ludicrous nonsense
bullcrap insane policy that has hurt
children in so many unspeakable ways I
interviewed to Mom on Long Island a
couple months ago when schools were
going back and forth over whether or not
they would remove their mask policy and
she was just telling me about her
experience I wrote about it for the site
but one of the worst parts of it she
told me was that there was a girl in the
school who got sick in class threw up in
her mask she's like in the second grade
and they made her walk to the nurse's
office without taking her mask off evil
like evil this is insane why would we
live this way well even before this did
you ever hear the story about what's
going on in Chicago where they they lock
kids in padded rooms there was a little
boy who was like acting out so they
brought him into a padded room locked
the door and then just left him there
for hours he started screaming he had to
go to the bathroom so they ignored him
and when his parents finally came they
found him like with crap on his pants
and he's like a little kid like like
after I hold he's like five or six or
something
so this stuff's been going on it's only
getting worse homeschool your kids
because uh one last point on the covet
stuff there was a study that I came
across it's um by Dr Raymond Palmer it's
called covid-19 vaccines and the
misinterpretation of perceived side
effects Clarity on the safety of
vaccines if you don't mind I'd like to
read a few lines what is what is the
what is uh with the basic premise is
that all of the side effects are just
because people were mean about it people
were mean on Twitter about about whether
or not they wanted to get vaccinated
they did a study that's not a real study
it's his contention
his contention is publication it's it's
published in um the Journal of
biomedicine in uh just last year is that
a reputable yes it is that's the
horrifying part
basically his much of this
anti-vaccination sentiment could be
attributed to the alleged side effects
that are perpetuated across social media
from anti-vaccination groups
fear-mongering and misinformation being
peddled by people with no scientific
training to terrorize people into
staying unvaccinated could be causing
the side effects in the vaccination
process but we're not talking about like
kids being masked we're talking about
it's in any kind of side this I just
came up I saw this today but any kind of
side effect of everything anything
socially because people are medically is
because of anti-vaxxers being mean on
social media well hold on there
guys we gotta stop being mean I know
that's the only way is that The Cure
well that's the you know everybody will
be healthier well to be fair I mean
stress does cause health problems it
does that's his contention I think his
contention is garbage well we can all
try to be a little nicer also like I
don't feel like the anti-vaxxers were
again about the Twitter user but I felt
like the dominant pressure was to get
vaccinated was to follow through and
those who questioned that were the ones
who were attacked he's literally
accusing people of what the
establishment was doing yes and by as a
perfect example perfectly described it
except for his side was doing well right
and what his contention was his his
evidence for it later and it is that
well women uh had more uh myocarditis
and different kinds of cardiac events
following
um you know exposure to social media and
it's because of that that there's this
this issue
it is plausible women are more likely to
have really severe stress reactions too
well social pressure
we talked about that study where like
teenage girls are getting depressed from
Instagram
I mean if if if if you are susceptible
for whatever reason be it covid or now
they like now they have that that study
that NBC News reported about where
they're doing Pfizer and modern I think
are doing long-term studies on on
myocarditis and pericarditis uh which
they say is very rare but my point is if
you are susceptible for whatever reason
and you're having heart palpitations
because of stress on social media
I mean I don't think anti-vaxxer makes
the most sense but the idea that social
media stress could make put you like put
increase your risk for any kind of uh
issue yeah just kind of a weird
convenient thing to to say no I think
we're seeing this increased stress in
people and it is causing them cardiac
issues it must be the anti-vaxxers on
social media that are responsible for it
which is again a convenient way to um
you could say it's cancel culture oh
sure the fear of being canceled of not
fitting in of not virtue signaling is
causing people to have heart problems I
actually would believe that too
especially with what we know I think you
know we've seen a lot of uh young girls
negatively impacted by social media they
get depressed when they don't get enough
likes but they're younger so they're not
their hearts aren't going to give up but
what if you're like a 50 60 year old
woman and you're you're wrapped up in
the stuff like I don't know if you guys
saw the Rosie O'Donnell Kathy Griffin
Tick Tock they put out and it's just
cringe like super cringe but I imagine
for them they're a lot older they're
active on social media they're probably
getting stressed out bad by the stuff
but they also just have old Hearts so
like I wouldn't be surprised if you came
to me and said that Kathy Griffin was
having a heart condition I'd be like
yeah the lady's strung out on Twitter
like she's losing it sure with a problem
with a study like that where he's making
his contention and his conclusion is
that well there's competing variables
here there's an alternative hypotheses
and you're just contending that this
must be the correct yeah yeah but that
one could very well be part of it as
well is that women really are getting
more stressed out because of social
pressures on on social media I think
it's fair to say that you know
myocarditis is not caused by Mean Tweets
I think I think I think that's the
Baseline that we should be having here
but hold on prove it prove it in a study
and then I'll I'll rely on Pfizer and
moderna to tell us what to believe in
since they're investigating themselves
so they're very trustworthy right but I
do think it's a fair point to say if
you're susceptible
it's being stressed out will like will
increase your risk probably like
cortisol stressors causes negative
Health consequences the point I'm trying
to bring up is guys I get it but social
media is is bad for us the algorithms
are manipulating us they're controlling
us into believing stupid political
nonsense and young girls are getting
depressed mostly young guys are getting
depressed too but it's mostly young
girls getting depressed by this I got no
problem being like I am absolutely
willing to throw the algorithms of
Facebook under the bus on this one if it
means we can I don't know do something
about it change it or fix it well there
are a couple uh wrongful death lawsuits
going there's one in the UK with like a
12 year old boy there's one in
California with like a 19 year old girl
who are uh they they basically are
arguing that the algorithms fed them
content that they may have been
predisposed to anxiety or issues but it
encouraged these mental health issues to
the point where at least one of the one
of the children killed themselves if
it's the 12 year old boy in the UK that
I'm thinking of then that lawsuit is is
completely bogus yeah because yes he was
being bullied online but he had horrible
home life and then it also turned out
that if that's the one I'm thinking of
that his mother then he had been he was
brain dead and was kept in line on
ventilators for three months while he
was literally his brainstem was
necrotizing while she was making money
by posting pictures of him on social
media in a diaper and if that's the same
story then I don't know I know there
have been several lawsuits I just find
it interesting and again maybe not all
of them are valid but I find it
interesting that people are choosing
this route to say like we are
experiencing the suffering right away we
didn't evolve in this in these
conditions whatsoever so of course it's
it's overstimulating to the the
diplominergic center of the brain
I want to I want to talk about chickens
so I'm just gonna hard segue and it's
Friday and so we're chilling but uh we
have the story from uh gbn
eggs to be rationed across UK until
spring 2023 supermarkets including Tesco
Asda and little taking urgent action
uh buy some chickens I look I don't know
if this is gonna happen here in the
United States probably not we're a very
very big country we have I think we've
got more Farmland in the UK they're not
they're not as large but the energy
crisis look I'm bringing up the eggs
thing just to be silly it is a very
serious story but uh with with what's
going on in in Ukraine and Russia the
latest report I saw was that Russia was
pulling back missile batteries and so
there's they're expecting a barrage to
come down like a serious one now like
Russia's not giving up on this and that
just means it's gonna get a lot worse
not the midterms are over and Joe Biden
has done dumping strategic petroleum the
prices are going to Skyrocket again and
now we're also hearing this 25 percent
of U.S faces potential winter
electricity outages fuel shortages have
increased risk to U.S power grid
so uh buy some chickens you know just a
couple in the backyard I guess if you
can and uh you know they'll eat the bugs
live in the pot and they'll give you
eggs but uh I would just say right now
we're looking at home prices collapsing
people don't want to buy
interest rates are going to go back up
inflation's getting worse gas prices are
going to Skyrocket the Band-Aid that
they put on the economy to try and save
Democrats in the midterms is now losing
its Effectiveness because abandoned over
a bullet wound can't do much for long so
uh I don't know what do you guys think
but well first of all I agree with the
buying chickens things we've got them
over in the UK so I guess we'll be all
right from the egg crisis that's coming
allegedly but yeah um absolutely it was
a Band-Aid as you said and it's it can't
do much for a prolonged period of time
to deal with the really disastrous
effects of the Joe Biden presidency that
were just temporarily ameliorated by
this in injection of money and people
are going to feel it and who are they
going to blame because the media will
say it's the it's the Republicans you
should have voted harder you didn't vote
hard enough so I don't know how are
people going to be able to explain that
to themselves and also the Trump
presidency from the lockdowns as well we
have to understand the lockdowns are
still having a very severe effect on our
economic way of life there's even major
shortages of antibiotics that people
can't find in U.S hospitals where
children are are left stranded and
screwed over because they don't have the
medicine because the supply shortages
from that lockdown are still affecting
our uh financial markets today which is
absolutely crazy and and I think think
we still haven't seen the rest of it yet
these Financial consequences of just
spending money giving people two
thousand dollar checks bring them back
the inflation reduction act which
doesn't really reduce inflation but
spends more money on climate and other
social justice Warrior causes that Bill
Gates Spurs on uh is not going to help
anyone we have to understand we're in
for some big trouble and there's no
denying it
this is kind of a segue but uh Biden's
80th birthday is Sunday and oh happy
birthday we did not get an annual
physical release this week which I
thought to be extremely annoying I know
that the Biden Administration is not
trustworthy but at least pretend I would
have liked to have seen the report that
inevitably would have declared that he
is competent and healthy and good at
stuff uh because at least then you are
keeping up the premise that you have to
pretend I don't trust the Biden
Administration and I am now concerned
that they aren't even pretending to hide
anything anymore they are openly not
talking about his health they're not
even walking through this yeah they're
not even I think the emperor has any
clothes at this point it's it's all like
well I guess everyone knows does anyone
really well they're stuck right if they
put out a clean bill Health everyone
goes um I don't think so and if they
don't they have to admit that he's not
going to run in 2024 and they're not
willing to do that either I feel like
this is such a strange power grab and I
feel sorry for my generation and
basically all Americans out there who
are having to pay the price for this you
know
I'm sad for this country
because we should be teaching our
younger generation how to think
critically and how to survive and we've
not done that and now we have a whole
bunch of you know whiny loser cultists
who are like I have to work eight hours
on Saturday we need a union and it's
like okay dude at this point I'm kind of
just like take your cities you can have
them I'm going to get away from the
cities move somewhere else and just try
and succeed and I I encourage everyone
else to do the same uh I'm not saying
abandon the political fight quite the
opposite I'm saying make sure you are
cleaning your room before you try to
change the world right and then my
attitude is your worst case scenario if
you get in shape Eat Right Start you
know working on yourself is that if it
all comes crumbling down
then uh you'll be all right you'll be
okay and the hipsters will be like why
can't we get avocado toast anymore and
you'll be like because they're grown in
Mexico in the winter and they ship them
here and now there's no energy because
you're an idiot
you don't want to do any work fine you
don't get your avocados I mean man look
at this Twitter stuff the Twitter melts
up they're like they're like I worked
four hours a week and Elon was and
doesn't want to pay me half a million
dollars and it's like uh-huh and it's
it's you know I've I've said it before
if the American people knew how much
money these like New York media people
were getting paid for as little work as
they're doing there would be a
revolution overnight Working Class
People in this country do not understand
you walk into that Google office these
people are all six figures and they do
nothing there's like they're I'm
watching people like sit there drinking
coffee reading a book I used to go there
and you know I'd be invited because
people I know people at Google I'd be in
their cafeteria I'm like so what is it
these people are doing it's remarkable
to me that when I worked for I worked at
O'Hare I'm lifting 50 000 pounds of
luggage every day for 10 bucks an hour
struggling to make ends meet couldn't
afford it and then when I walked in that
Vice office for the first time I just
started laughing I was like where is
everybody and like I work from home
what they published like one article per
week amazing
work advice one article a week well
they're laying people off now yeah there
was a that's right here that went viral
a couple of months ago was it a week's
ago uh no it wasn't about Twitter it was
about LinkedIn yeah right where the the
woman is like here's a day in the life
of a 23 year old whatever at LinkedIn
and she just it all she seemed to do was
sit around and eat snacks like we were
talking about the journalist yesterday
he was driving a Ferrari in a five
million dollar mansion
excuse me you got the difference there
come on Lewis what's going on listen huh
it's still ridiculous and again there
there is so much of of these people that
take so much for granted they're so
entitled and we're so lucky to even be
born in the United States when you we
compare how we live to how the rest of
the world lives there's a big difference
if you travel the world you see you see
it and it's shocking it's terrifying and
to see people take advantage of that and
to to see people just not want to work
hard in this situation not take all the
opportunities present it to them is just
mind-boggling to me personally at least
but uh yeah aha I would never want to
build advice ever they're Cod people
yeah they're NPCs like
look
Good Times make weak men
yeah you got a lot of people who are
born into the the the peak of American
gluttony they do no work they never had
to work they never had hardship and now
they're thrust into the world and uh I
mean we weren't look we used to say that
these woke people got out of college
they're in for a rude awakening we were
half right most of them were in for a
rude awakening got really angry and now
are voting to make the world like their
daycare campus but we're also seeing
funny videos of people being like they
scheduled me for eight hours on the
weekend I need a union
that's a great one eight hours on the
weekend I know Heaven's me wow no I have
to lift a rock to Lewis's Point like
both of my this is horrible I don't know
why we started this but like I mean I
know you have a similar story but both
of my parents are immigrants and I
remember asking my dad once do you ever
wish that you know he had opportunity to
move back and then before they had kids
and I remember asking him like do you
ever wish that I had your accent do you
ever wish I was more in touch with that
part of our culture
um and he was like no we knew it was a
dying country like we left so you would
have opportunities that we did not think
you would have in the UK like that was
more important and I think that that is
a perspective that so many people don't
have like they assume that things will
always continue to get better and better
and when they're faced with challenges
they aren't willing to think critically
about the sacrifices that have been made
for them or that they need to make for
their future yeah Gila is absolutely
right uh there's hilarious there's a
reason people in in Poland literally
have their own jaucus Jaco are called
little plots of land that they have
outside of their major apartment
buildings where they just grow their own
food they also preserve their own food
can their own food and growing up in
Poland it was routine during winter oh
yeah we make reserves and and we have
reserves that we could eat so we don't
have to rely on the Communist
centralized government force that will
give you a piece of paper allowing you a
certain allowance of of bread of meat
that you were given as a ration that
everyone was allowed to have which is
absolutely crazy you would have your own
by being prepared and I think with the
government here becoming more
centralized that's something that more
and more people need to realize that at
the end of the day you are only
responsible for yourself especially when
it comes to the larger crap storm coming
our way that the government is creating
well I feel like you're Leonard's right
you're responsible for yourself but also
you're responsible for your progeny and
your family and your immediate Community
like you choose who you interact with
day today and the impact that you have
on them like don't trust the government
to make things better that's what I
don't understand about people coming out
of college who are just waiting for
someone to fix their problems like
that's never been realistic I don't know
what experience you had in life that
made you feel that way it was crazy when
uh I was working for a company
I I had a uh somebody
fresh out of college first job
and they were telling me I don't know
how to do this task someone needs to
tell me how to do it and my response was
well just figure it out and they're like
what do you mean just figure I need to
be told what to do and I was like take
the time to figure out how to operate
the system and then I had to explain to
them I was like
if someone else knew how to do it they
wouldn't have hired you to do it but I
get it in college you have a professor
who tells you how to do things that's
not how it works here you're hired
because nobody knows how to do it and
it's your job to figure it out
surprise surprise these people struggle
yeah they can't they can't make it well
just I think they're living in a myth
there's something called the wig
interpretation of History they may have
heard of and it does rely on this belief
system that things are always
progressing forward in an upward and
onward Direction so we have more
technology we have more freedom whatever
that is supposed to mean under certain
circumstance but because we have more of
stuff therefore everything else about
Society must be better and it's I think
really bunk I I talk about this too
people are like this is the first
generation where we're worse off than
our parents and I was like I don't know
if that's true because my parents didn't
have cell phones when they were younger
they didn't have access to the summation
of human knowledge they couldn't argue
with strangers and look at pictures of
cats you know For Better or For Worse
and it was even really difficult to get
TVs you're very expensive so
if you wanted to go out Friday night
with you know grab drinks with your
friends like good luck try calling the
phone leaving a message otherwise
nothing so we do have a lot more
luxuries they did they didn't have now
that being said because of these things
good luck getting a job if you don't
have a cell phone
so now it's a necessity you it may be
benefit beneficial to you which means we
may have better things but we we don't
have the excess cash to start families
so you know the things you all end up
owning you but let's talk about colleges
I want to talk about the story we got
here from uh Daily Mail University of
California Santa Barbara's black student
union holds free black panther wakanda
forever screening but asks white
students not to attend
oh yes this is what they mean by
diversity racial segregation
so uh there's another article from the
Philadelphia Inquirer that was talking
about the writer was Mexican and he was
saying how you know he didn't understand
Black Panther and what it meant for the
black community seeing an African
country that wasn't devastated by
colonization and then he was like and
then I saw no more and and nutello Khan
in wakanda forever and then I started to
understand and I'm just thinking like
these woke people
their view of what is good in terms of
racial like racial ideology is
stereotypes of races totally segregated
and fighting with each other that was
the craziest thing like
black panther have you seen it oh hell
no well why not thank you why not I I
love comic books I like Namor by the way
so I have no interest in Namor is that
how it's pronounced now okay well not
not for my entire life of reading Marvel
Comics but what I don't think I'm
supposed to roll the r but well I don't
know they've changed it and so exactly I
have no I mean my character's gotta I'm
not Daredevil shirt which is not from a
particularly good run on Daredevil by
Mark Wade but um I have no interest in
modern Comics because they had no
interest in me but what what what don't
you like about Black Panther
I thought the first movie was okay yeah
but it was like it was it was like it
was crazy it was a good I it was a good
movie but I just I don't think I can't
watch any of this stuff was a wakanda
first close right which was bizarre that
they did make him a a you know wakanda
nationalist I'm gonna spoil it I mean
I've already spoiled it a million times
but you see this is this is Judge in a
book by by its cover wakanda forever the
point I'm making about how racist this
is is a movie quite literally about the
most powerful Nation on Earth so says
Queen ramonda with a powerful barrier
around their country that no one can
breach and a Mexican guy breaks in by
crossing a river oh I I missed your
video about it hilarious sorry I've
heard some other people talk about it so
I I'm aware of what happens in the film
and they're cheering for it they're like
this is the greatest movie and it's
funny because we had Dave Landau here
and when we were talking about it before
the show and I explained it's a Mexican
guy and his back you know as he climbs
out of the river is wet and I said how
do you think they defeat him and he goes
do they dry him off and I was like yes
yes and he was like so it's the greatest
movie ever right yeah stereotypes are
are a simple way of understanding the
world and that it's also something
called a cognitive heuristic we all rely
on cognitive heuristics as mental
shortcuts so for example if you see a
stick in the grass we have evolved to
very quickly make a snap judgment to
decide if that is a stick in the grass
or a snake it reduces cognitive load to
rely upon stereotypes it literally means
you have to think less they expend less
mental energy so people like stereotypes
for that reason so I think that maybe in
some way they're just like oh I don't
have to I can turn my brain off even
more during this Marvel movie than I
usually would because I can just rely
upon stereotypes about other people now
now that we've we've entertained that
and we talked about it before I have
this story from indiewire John Leguizamo
calls out non-diverse Super Mario
Brothers casting it's going backwards
for them to go backwards and not cast
another actor of color kind of sucks
like wazama who starred in the 1993
live-action version of the upcoming
animated movie let me just explain this
very simply Mario and Luigi are two
white plumbers John Leguizamo is angry
that two white guys were cast to play as
white plumbers this is the extent of
wokeness in in
culture it sounds like they're making
the like far right position or argument
that Italians aren't White
that's what I that's what I was thinking
too like uh that's really weird it is
bizarre It's News to the white Italians
but I've seen that like like very far
right people will say because of
um
proximity to Africa that Italians aren't
really white if that's what you're
saying then I mean okay well like you
and Richard Spencer can be buddies but
here's here's the thing you want to know
what this really about John Leguizamo
played Luigi in 1993 right and he wants
to play Luigi now it's a big role it's
big money and he's mad they're not
casting him so he makes it about race
and says it's going backwards bro if the
argument is that people should only play
characters that are their race then you
should be happy that white actors were
cast to play White characters the the
concern was when you had black
characters voiced by white people
no apparently now the concern is for the
the entire time all these people ever
really cared about was empowering
themselves and making money as the only
person of color here in this room I
think it's I think every Studio should
follow Netflix's uh protocol and make
you know all the characters uh as
diverse as they possibly can no matter
how ridiculous or absurd it is and the
memes are absolutely hilarious too
the book says that they cut the white
bread and it's a piece of France I
tweeted that one today too uh but but
yeah this is just just people going
crazy I think this is just something
highlighting our our mental health
decline I think a lot of people aren't
well I think this is a perfect example
of it and I think this kind of uh
regurgitation of nonsense is just
becoming more and more normalized and
there's some woke companies that
actually follow these principles which
is absolutely absurd uh it's stupid it's
discriminatory it's racist it's
ridiculous I mean I think part of it is
that the implication is that white
people are meant to be secondary or
replaceable I think part of it is you
know to compensate the when I was in
college what I heard regularly was that
because white people have traditionally
held institution of power it's not even
that you need to have representation you
need to have over representation to
compensate right so we can't have white
Italian plumbers because they should
have always been diverse to make up for
the fact like it's such a trap and at
the end of it you just hear that white
culture is not real and fake like I am
sure you could get an Italian actor what
was the uh the mayor of La he was like I
I am diverse because I am Italian I
identify with the Latino Community
excuse me what like there is such an
interest in divorcing yourself from
Western European culture of course if
you can grab at some kind of power and I
think that's because we're repeatedly
told that it's supposed to be a race
we're not supposed to see it anymore
we'll just make up for wrongs from the
past yes that's where you get the Rachel
dolezels right of I'm gonna essentially
you know
play at a Minstrel show because this is
how I gain institutional power by
pretending that I'm I'm anything but
white like how come X and talcum or Luke
hey hey I'm officially recognized I got
the paperwork to prove it but watch out
Tim from where where did you get people
how many people are people of color
exactly listen here Helen Claire
don't you challenge me for me
right that's racist completely the
non-minority in the room I'm just gonna
say it I'm you're the whitest person in
this room all right you should not have
a voice here I don't know what surge is
doing over here that's true he's second
in line and I speak first as the
dominant wife's voice in this room no
I'm just kidding but I I mean I think
this is this strange white guilt that we
see cultivated that it's it's
um like he thinks someone will clap him
on the back he'll get this maybe a
write-up because he I mean I don't know
maybe this guy is super relevant maybe
we hear from him all the time not
recently right so the only time he
surfaces when he can denounce casting
white people like that seems like a
weird yeah it seems terrible well who's
who's gonna
um say anything against him in the
mainstream media nobody this is just
he'll just get applauded for this that's
the main issue he worries about how
privileged does he have to be how how
lucky does he have to be to live in a
world where this is his major issue this
is what he decides to to Rally behind
there's so much economic inequality
there's so much horrible things
happening with our health there's so
much corruption within our political
system there's so many multinational
corporations and big Banks screwing
everyone over and this is what your main
issue is come on man I wonder what
compelled him to star in the past you
ever see that movie no nobody knows that
reference oh man it probably means
I would say to counter your point though
Luke just a little bit media and culture
do actually matter which is why it's
cool that you guys are doing so much of
what you are doing and I think that
they're aware of that and that's why he
made the comment that he did because he
is aware on some level that media
culture does matter and so he has to
make his weird I'm just going to Virtue
signal statement I'm I'm bringing up
this movie as kind of a dig against him
because like if he wants to act out I'm
gonna mention that he starred in the
film The Pest which is like a really
really bad late 90s movie that cost
eight million dollars and only made 3.6
so uh what's the plot man I don't
remember was it diverse though I guess
he's like did he take a spot away from
me yeah that's that is the operative
question he gets hunted for sport or
something
because he's white that would be like
you could make that yeah today that
would be the funny thing is like
apparently there's this this issue
because he claims he's Puerto Rican John
Leguizamo but his dad came out he's like
he's Colombian okay there was a movie
about that I thought that came out about
a white family being hunted not that
long ago there was that actually it was
really good uh the Hunt is that it yeah
like everyone thought the movie was
explicitly just like conservatives being
hunted oh yeah the film was actually a
bit more nuanced than that and actually
was pretty good yeah I didn't I didn't
see it the Liberals were the bad guys oh
okay yeah like outright just really
stupid and evil and they end up
I'll give you I'll spoil it for
everybody because I think it's been out
for a few years it's probably okay so
the trailer made it seem like
conservatives get hunted by liberals
you watch the film the Liberals are
clearly the villains and they kidnap
incorrectly some woman because they had
bad information so not only were they
evil for trying to hunt and kill like
middle Americans who just have to be
conservative the main character happens
to have been incorrectly kidnapped and
they try murdering her and then in the
end even though the woman knows like
whoops you're trying to kill an innocent
person the liberal man still wants to so
it's like they're outright just the bad
guys so I was like actually you know do
you think the people who saw that movie
were able to catch on to the message
they're explicitly the bad guys it's
like she's that doesn't necessarily mean
people understood it so it's like she's
her and her friends I mean I think it
was well done her she's driving a text
group and then someone posts a joke
about eating babies or something and
then it gets leaked and then a
conspiracy theory forms about it so they
decide they're going to murder it
they're going to kidnap and murder
anyone who believes the conspiracy they
end up grabbing a woman of the same name
as someone else online she's totally
innocent and has nothing to do with
anything it's not political at all and
then and she ends up killing them all so
like I think it was actually well done
she's like you got the wrong person I
don't care about any of this she's like
I just want to go home but you know I
thought it was uh I actually thought it
was maybe the criticism still stands
like at a time when there's as much
political division we shouldn't put out
movies that are like that but it was not
a movie where the message overtly was
haha go hunt and kill conservatives
but that's what the trailer made it look
like so maybe they could have done a
better job right yeah
could act in part two of that there you
go there you go here's a job for you
yeah but they got everyone talking about
it so they got everyone right no they
canceled it remember though like they
they yeah they they pulled it and then
then later on they said okay we're gonna
bring the movie back yeah I don't
remember that part of it I remember
hearing about it even Trump was tweeting
about it what better way to promote a
movie than have the president of the
United States tweet at it well now he
can't do that anymore is the verb truth
he truth he truths I believe yeah yeah
look trumpet it originally was going to
be September 27th and then they said
they were canceling and then later they
brought it back March 13th
yeah
yeah it made money 14 million budget
42.8 million dollar Revenue well yeah
again the the tactic worked then for one
one reason or another
yeah
there you go
anyway
a bit of an aside yeah as an aside uh
watch the movie there you go what other
movies should we watch
um going to the weekend what are your
recommendations going into the weekend
uh it's it's it's uh wakanda forever
obviously because it's funny how the
woke people are like yeah this would be
so good and I'm like this movie is like
super yeah it's it's but but like so the
first problem with the first one was the
first one the first but it was the first
one was a a
patriarchal
Ultra nationalist country
ethnocentric ethno ethnonationalist
in order to rule you had to win trial by
combat and and be a man
women weren't allowed to rule
and then the villain was basically an
ethno supremacist who wanted to use the
superior weapons to take over the world
for their race it's like that's an
interesting narrative it was the good
guy was Trump the bad guy was Hitler and
then you have part two where this
powerful Nation wants to mind its own
business and then Mexicans are crossing
through the river into the country
wreaking havoc I'm like who are they
making this movie for who is the writer
for this movie I need to know who was
sitting there like uh-huh okay and what
should we do next okay we shouldn't have
Namor be Atlantean because of copyright
issues let's have him be Mexican and
then he breaks into wakanda for some
reason a landlocked Nation by crossing
the left border wall no no like I don't
know what it is oh that's funny it was
over copyright reasons that he couldn't
be from Atlantis they I guess the issue
was uh Brett from pop culture crisis was
telling me this that uh they didn't want
to pay the original Creator or like his
estate so by substantively changing
Neymar to Namor which was uh he was the
child without love right so in Spanish
she was like my enemies call me Namor oh
it's like okay dude no your enemies
don't call you that one guy called you
that 500 years ago you're cringing over
there yeah that's all I didn't unders I
didn't know about that part but this is
why I don't watch these movies and I
don't watch them I don't watch what is
it rings of power I will watch
um
other people on YouTube do five hour
long reviews of them for sure because I
find that entertaining I have to imagine
though with like black panther you'll
end up with white identitarians and the
woke vegetarians sitting in the theater
together cheering for the same messages
I saw that with the first one on you
know like the four on 4chan when the
first one came out there were people you
know the people who self-identify as
Nazis being like Oh we love this this is
great we've got this Ultra nationalistic
Movie great and they're all cheering for
and they love it yes and then they're
doing that uh that that University of
California Santa Barbara is doing a
black only screen right
there could be some like CIA reverse
psychology here because if you look at a
lot of Mainline movies it's usually
going against the big evil government or
the multinational corporation or some
kind of evil villain that wants to
reduce the Earth's population for the
greater good I I think there might be
some kind of psyops here just again
speculating here totally out of nowhere
uh of them just being like you know
we're gonna put this in your head just
so you don't see it in real life
potentially I think I think there's
something to think about what are they
trying to put in your head
um or they're trying to to to to you
know put that satisfaction of rebellion
in your head so it doesn't come to
fruition in real life I'll give you an
example that's a V for Vendetta all the
movies are like this there's a show we
talked about this on the members only uh
The Matrix there's a there's a show
called The Good Fight
they did an episode I think it was the
finale where a character based on
milianopolis accuses Ron DeSantis by
name yeah of sexual assault
and in the show they are saying over and
over again Rhonda Santos accused and
here's the guy saying and I thought it
was interesting so we googled Ron
DeSantis the good fight and what do you
find is so weird Ronda Santos has many
interviews where he says I'm going to
keep fighting the good fight it just so
happens a show called The Good Fight
comes out where Ron DeSantis is accused
of sexual assault so what happens now
when you Google search Ronda said this
the good fight what a vile psyop you see
posts about sexual assault yeah and so
maybe it's all just one big coincidence
but man was that very perfect that
wasn't the craziest aspect over the
entire episode at the end Donald Trump
runs to be president of the United
States and the whole and this is before
he announced but the whole premise of
the episode is a terrorist attack by
right Wingers that are surrounding this
black lawyer firm there's 20 000 of them
outside and then they stage an attack on
them that's going to assassinate all of
them as they're shooting machine guns uh
into their building and that was
actually happening in the show that's
that's the plot of the show the plot of
the show is that they're working and
these uh they wore the same outfits as
the Patriot front and there's 20 000 of
them outside in Chicago causing riots
everywhere and then they stage an attack
where they uh you know make sure that
they block all the exits and then they
go on the roof and start shooting and
trying to assassinate all the children
and workers inside of this predominantly
all black lawyer here is this supposed
to be taking place this is the last
episode of this series that came out of
the and it's it's the same it's the same
episode as the dissentice right I know
are these episodes Standalone I have no
idea like like I said is it an anthology
show where every episode is its own
contained little mini film I I think
it's a series that continues how do you
how do you how do you do a season after
that
I think that was their season finale I
know but like the start of the next
season is like so after like Civil War
started
I I think it's during a civil war anyway
my point is I think they do these things
in media uh because like there's that
famous line from Tina Fey where she said
I can see Russia from my house and then
what happened was a bunch of liberals
started saying Sarah Palin said she
could see Russia from her house no that
was Tina Fey Sarah Palin said actually
from the westernmost point of Alaska you
can see Russian territory we have to
negotiate with Russia because of the
straight and trade routes which is
actually an excellent point when you're
running for office and explaining that
you have to negotiate with Russia now
and then Tina Fey made fun of her in a
way that made no sense and now these
people believe that was the actual quote
so it's called the Primacy effect in
terms of whatever people see first is
what they tend to believe and when you
have mass media versus some news
individual news reports people believe
what they see first and tend to hold on
to that information even after it has
been corrected so one of the like really
I guess if you want to go along with all
of the beliefs about how bad fake news
is the real problem problem with fake
news such as it does exist is that it
doesn't matter
there's several studies on this it
doesn't matter if you update the news
article people will remember what they
read first there's a competing Theory
called the recency effect that people
will remember whatever they heard most
recently however it has far less robust
support within the data the Primacy
effect is what we see very consistency
very consistently excuse me that
whenever people hear first or C first
sticks within their mind and that's what
they recall yep so is there like an
emotional bond because of that first
initial reaction it could there could be
an emotional aspect to it but it's more
that people are just taking in
information going okay this is
interesting or funny and if you make it
funny by the way it's called
instructional humor processing Theory
and what that finds is that if you're
trying to teach something teach
something to anybody make it funny
because it increases recall I love the
conspiracy theory that the government
funds movies to block conspiracy
theories like Men In Black for instance
the conspiracy theory is that Men In
Black are real so they make a movie
about it that's very exaggerated and
silly so that way if anyone ever says I
was visited by Men In Black they go like
the movie oh it's an episode of Stargate
sg1 like that Wormhole extreme right
right we actually had coronamic here
last week it was super cool so actually
the episode of cast Castle we did was
Ian is convinced that Koran is actually
Jonas Quinn okay and then that's that's
basically the premise where it's like it
was funny because when we were writing
it I was like that's actually an episode
of Stargate sg1 Wormhole extreme is a TV
show because like this yeah anyway and
Supernatural that was a plot line in
Supernatural where girl God was actually
sending Divine messages to some kooky
guy who wrote books about the actual
characters in the show and Etc et cetera
so several shows have played with this
yeah you were telling us about a lot of
different theories that you were
studying and looking into before we
started the show what's one of the most
interesting study that you looked into
when it comes to psychology and our
current kind of kind of modern day
Society that's that's I know I know I
like to ask these questions but my
favorite ones are mostly deal with
parasociality and studying of the
internet how people form fake
relationships that they feel are very
real with people online and this can
also include characters from media where
because we didn't evolve in a mediated
environment it's very difficult for
people to be able to delineate what is a
real interaction from what is a fake or
pseudo or parasocial interaction I love
that it's a whole broad field but I the
parasociality stuff and particularly now
when we have this constant interaction
with Twitter and people feel like they
know Donald Trump or they feel like they
know XYZ person that can have some very
harmful effects as well because well
what if your internet friend doesn't
respond in turn and there's tons of
research that's become very very popular
almost to the point of bringing it up is
probably trite at this point but it's
called a lot of it referred to with
family vloggers and oh yeah like the
concept of putting your kid in danger
because people think they have a uh they
have apparel social relationship with
your child who doesn't know anything
about it because the concept of the
internet is difficult when you're five
the idea of family vlogging is
horrifying to me because you're putting
the child out there and exposing them to
this constant Deluge of media exposure
before they're able to form any kind of
sense of self so or consent right they
certainly can't consent yeah human
beings aren't built to be okay with
social media they aren't built to deal
with so much attention so much feedback
so much comment so much interactions all
at once we used to be small tribes
that's what our body and mental state is
used to to being and I think this is one
reason why we're seeing such a huge uh
increase of mental health well the
dopamine system is fried the dopamine
system it actually the prolonged
exposure to this kind of stuff
constantly day after day after day it
causes the parts of your brain that
produce and regulate dopamine to become
a eventually unable to continue to
produce it at the same level so people
become just like any other addiction
they become addicted to the substance in
this case dopamine hit oh a like your
retweet on Twitter that kind of thing at
some point your brain cannot keep
stimulating you and feeding you the
positive feedback chemical that you want
from it and then it actually physically
shrinks in size your parts of your brain
physically shrink in size because it
cannot keep doing this but you also need
more as your body is less able to
provide it can you like inject dopamine
sure surely like I mean like not like
yeah does it have the same effect I
wouldn't I haven't read any studies on
that but I would assume so and then
probably they'll probably be like the
next big thing because like adrenochrome
yeah you got to get the adrenochrome but
I would with meta The Proposal of meta
and and that VR stuff it's now every
single human sense is being stimulated
your dopamine systems the whole
dopaminergic system is going to be fried
for people and there's going to be no
way for them to get the dopamine that
they are so craving because their own
body can't produce it anymore and once
your brain shrinks sorry once your brain
shrinks there's no coming back it can
yeah sure so like is there a treatment
for disconnect
uh no what's the same thing with any
other addiction
more or less yeah well also there's also
very negative effects especially when it
comes to online pornography and I think
also with things like Tick-Tock becoming
more and more popular this is kind of
the larger symptom of a society getting
sicker and sicker needing a quicker
dopamine needing a quicker fix needing a
quicker stimulation uh just more and
more uh quicker quicker quicker faster
faster faster Tick Tock is completely
exemplary of that in that it's five to
ten seconds you get my stimulus and my
output and I'm good to go and now next
next and it never stops yeah where do
you see this going where where is
society heading and and where's the
crash how does it look like well in the
experiments they did with rats which is
always a good way to start a sentence
when you talk about the future of
society in the studies that have been
done with rats for example they put a
electrode in the pleasure center of the
brain in rats and they gave them a
little button and they could just sit
there and push the button to stimulate
the the pleasure center of the brain
they found that much as with the rat
Utopia experiment after a while they
stopped eating they stopped reproducing
they stopped having sex they stopped
cleaning themselves to the point where
they would just sit there and press the
button over and over again until they'd
essentially die so there's the
horrifying there's the really horrifying
potential future but uh let's go meta
right
thank goodness that company's failing
thank goodness they're losing so much
money don't go in the pods don't Don't
Put on We Are said please just imagine
not knowing what like accomplishment is
what drives us right getting more likes
we're we're like feeling a connection to
something happening but it really is
just that dopamine release there's two
two forms of pleasure that exist um it's
eudemonia and hedonia hedonia is pure
physical pleasure just a feeling good
eudemonia is a sense of meaningfulness
and that's what we're losing but so like
I'm imagining if there was a button that
could stimulate your brain you wouldn't
know why it was good you'd just be like
this is great for some reason it just
keeps smashing the button it's called
Tick Tock yeah yeah it is that's it but
my point is on Tick Tock they do they're
like I'm seeing someone Dance I'm seeing
some social interaction yeah but do they
remember it when they get consumed so
much information so quickly uh one one
thing after another thing after another
thing do they really remember it the
recall is not the part of it that
matters it's the instant instantaneous
dopaminergic stimulation and again
what's what's that's all the hedonia the
eudaemonia which are things like again
it's commonly called meaningfulness of a
feeling of accomplishment a feeling of
having done something that's bigger than
yourself I when we look there's
longitudinal studies on human happiness
we find produces longitudinal human
happiness is not pleasure it's hedonia
it's having children it's having a home
it's raising a family it's having
relationships meaningful ones with other
people and that's not dopaminergically
stimulating we're gonna go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.com I want to point out
something really quick Elon musk's
Twitter poll currently with 3.13 million
votes Donald Trump is winning his
election on Twitter with 58 to 42 and
that is very significant because
Twitter is more left-wing than right
wing there are more leftist active users
than right-wing active users according
to tons of different studies and
different data this means there are a
lot of people on there who are like yeah
he shouldn't have been banned so
considering that fact if y'all have
Twitter you should go on to elon's
account and vote for Trump to be
reinstated
someone pointed out that because of the
size of elon's audience these polls are
statistically significant or meaning
it's physically significant with 500.
yeah depending on depending on where
it's it's hard to know if you're doing
500 people like where are you targeting
and who are these people but with 3.1
million well with 116 million total
reach and 3.1 million you can take take
into consideration the current time of
day and then you can say it it will
likely be this uh this region United
States he he just posted a few hours ago
so it's gonna hit West Coast to East
Coast might not hit you know well
actually yeah I think it'll hit the
entirety even Alaska and Hawaii so it
matters
all right let's read some super chats
knuckle fist says Twitter runs on Amazon
AWS Elon doesn't want parlord that's
right
yeah they'll get their servers nuked
what do we got here OMG puppy says we
should be upset about Democrats
blackmailing advertisers to bankrupt
Twitter Elon needs support and time to
make changes now is at the time for
Perfection enemy of the good stuff
my point is I totally get all that but
why insult Alex Jones's fans why insult
the the the culture Warriors who believe
in free speech he could have just
avoided the subject
or he could have just been like there's
a lot more we have to work through
before we unban everybody
we'll see what happens you know what I
mean
yamabushi says why do I even bother
clicking notify on this show anymore
YouTube literally never lets me know
when the show starts and uh technically
every episode should be trending
but uh you know that's just the way it
goes has it ever trended like how long
has it been I actually think we may have
trended uh early on uh we were trending
maybe a couple times and then you know
we get political and then not So Much
Anymore yeah that's how it goes yeah I
got a notification today I will add
though uh
is the biggest month we've ever had in
terms of viewership on this channel
so that's cool
yep
Jim Bob says Kathy did the bloody
trumpet that is far worse than what Alex
did absolutely vile I Won't Back Elon
anymore over this Tim this is all
exhausting I hear you but uh
I don't think the answer is necessarily
completely turn around that's why I was
saying I'll pull back and be like okay
okay okay hold on there a minute I'm
willing to put some money into this
Twitter to see if he can get it right
but and I understand the difficulty with
Alex Jones but the too bad no uh I don't
like that I don't like that at all
it's it's all or nothing man
Raymond g Stanley Jr says crystal ball
don't expect a billionaire to save you
agreed
yep
dread Max says if Twitter is
predominantly lefties how does Trump
have a 62 favorable vote well it's down
to 58 but yes agreed good point because
uh because they like Trump it's funny on
Twitter he was hilarious even if he was
you know uh I brought up instructional
humor processing Theory but there's also
several theories of humor which
illustrate that you have to violate an
expectancy violation you have to say
something unexpected or
crazy or whatever to actually make
people laugh that's a big key element of
humor and if you can only say
predictable things then people won't
laugh at it and if that's what Elon
thinks Twitter is about is being funny
which is what he said no Trump no funny
accurate information with that too I
guess yeah waffle sense is a very
important question Hannah Claire did you
finish Tokyo Drift yet
no for those who don't know I have to
watch all of the Fast and Furious movies
not Tokyo Drift
I don't know the agreements I have to
watch all of them it turns out that's
like 19 hours of my life I've only
watched two this became what kind of
agreement is this it was like they deal
with the devil yeah I it's Brett and
Mary that's you it's um they had they
had to get to
um um like 11 or 25 crisis parties in
one show and oh yeah they manage that
and it's crazy now I have to invest a
lot of time I have not watched Tokyo
Drift I will do it eventually I actually
don't watch a lot of movies so this is
extremely hard I think I'm gonna have to
watch them all in one weekend I I don't
think you gotta watch Tokyo Drift
because it's outside of the like the
series but it Loops back in the
character does re-enter the franchise
later a deal is a deal Heidi don't let
the people down Liam you were never a
part of this just calm down no I feel
like I have to honor it pop culture was
really hard and it's cool I guess that
their fans are devoted what I don't
understand is that you guys are using
real names like at this point just call
them Loveless hey I said huh Tom you're
not
get out of here Tom holore
Theodore you're not a part of this get
out of here
Hayden says Jones put out a response
video to Elon saying not to bring him
back Joan's response was great I get it
but I feel also feel like Alex has to
say that you know that what you you
brought it up right Luke if he came out
and he was like screw you Elon like he's
never coming back then you know
old stick key taint says voting for
Trump's unbanning is a smart move forced
these advertisers to just to justify why
they want to pull advertisements when
the majority of their target audience
wants him on
I think they've proven they're clearly
ideological way past this point that
money doesn't matter as much as the
message well and I would love if that
was how it worked you do the poll
Trump's ahead but didn't didn't we all
just talk about the fact that Elon was
like these polls are not good because of
the Bots yeah like we can't do this
until the Bots are purged so really easy
focusing on the one thing he needs to do
which is Purge the Bots Larry made that
point well uh SC federali says where the
f is Ian Milo is self-absorbed you guys
drug Ian without a mic afterward dirty I
knew I shouldn't sub give him a mic
friends uh who's he in yeah I'm Ian now
Ian who you mean Ian Claire Ian Claire
it's me uh he and he and Claire the
thing is like Ian and I had this big
fight in the parking lot and I won and I
get the chair so yeah that's how it
works yeah we have a we have a a boxing
ring outside poor guy's crying well he
said he needs to train more you know
yeah I know I've been trying
speaking of that Jeffrey Max is so happy
to see Hannah Claire please have her on
more oh well there you go Tim I'm the
poll is winning they want me back
thank you so much this is really nice
this is why the potato man's not here he
got beat I'm a really good boxer I don't
know what to tell you guys yeah I've
been I've been training survival of the
fittest
no I actually love doing the show it's
been fun uh and also when you are on the
news team it's interesting to be here
because every time like I'll watch the
show in the room and be like I know that
article oh oh I know who or that like
yeah it's like inside baseball I guess
stinky whistle teats says elon's
apparent indifference to censorship
wasn't really shocking now Jordan
Peterson's tweets calling for it was
truly shocking and depressing yeah yeah
did you happen to see them no what did
he say um he he basically called for
like a getting rid of the plebs yes
punishing the plebs and making sure that
they can't troll people because which is
ridiculous yeah he's it was really awful
he's like I'm so tired of the he said
like he had the nasty mean trolls on
Twitter that are awful it was very
elitist it was very elitist I mean but
the daily wire might be getting to him
and asking for in return what was done
to him which you know this is eye for an
eye stuff that I don't think is the way
you want to go with it Jordan well when
he said consign the anonymous
narcissists and Psychopaths to troll
hell yeah that one I think that's if
you're gonna go after anyone the most
vile people are the verified people or
the big corporate media accounts are the
you know leftists that call for people
to die and show people's heads on a
stake those those are vile people the
anonymous people they're not that bad
compared to the the the really bad
people out there Chuck Taylor says a
special counsel was appointed today how
is that not the lead story
because so what
a special counsel got appointed yeah for
what reason Trump had some classified
documents and he had plenary plenary
declassification power waste of my time
sorry I I don't know not to be
dismissive no it's it's been this it's
the same thing being repeated Ad nauseam
at this point but it's like it's not an
impeachment there's nothing substantive
fear the special counsel goes nowhere
it's a waste of everyone's time Trump
has the ability the ability to classify
whatever he wants he apparently just had
the folders anyway which still are
classified but it's just like do I care
about this he was the President right I
mean the story there is just Trump
declares bid for reelection and they're
like actually we've really got to buckle
down on this investigation that we've
had for like a year and a half but again
is anyone surprised by that no
pinochet's helicopter tour says Tim it
goes both ways Elon can out every one of
these corporations and advertisers
subverting the people's constitutional
rights ESG is to blame here and he
should didn't Elon say something about
doing that
making known every corporation or
something that that you know
I think so maybe he did I don't know
maybe maybe someone else did yeah I
don't recall but Elon you know what I
would do if a corporation was like we
don't want these people on the platform
like okay here's what I'll do for you
I will take your company's logo and
default it on the page of those people
you don't like hmm that's it
yeah why not
what is it isn't Yelp accused of doing
something like that where if you don't
sign up they'll put the negative reviews
at the top well it's kind of just a
ridiculous sort of um demand in the
first place because it's like I mean
would this happen on traditional um you
know media as if like oh you have
somebody on or some show on that that a
corporation doesn't 100 agree with so
they're gonna they demand that that show
that person that episode be pulled I
guess it does work sometimes but it's
it's a big ask and it depends I guess on
the corporation I mean it didn't happen
to Carlson a bunch of his editors pulled
out they did but but Fox News didn't get
rid of him and that was a lot of people
I mean I'm just saying like it would be
it would be as if there was one very
special episode of I don't know pick
Full House or something where then you
know somebody uh got canceled in the
future and they hadn't yet pulled the
episode and then advertisers said we
will not run our ads on
um whatever said Network because of this
thing that happened in the past
so Jim Bob says Tim would you kindly
give me an Ian Crystal Jim Bob here's
what I'll do I am going to write down
Jim Bob
and uh go to the latest members only
videos
comment that you would like an Ian
Crystal I will then instruct the team to
seek out your comment reach out to you
and then send you an Ian Crystal of
course pending Ian's approval to send
out one of the crystals I just don't
like it I get to do I get to pick which
one goes out no no Ian probably will I
guess they're his so well Fair
technically I got him out of a big
barrel at um
where were we yeah no stealing Harley we
had some gorge in West Virginia it was
really a new River uh maybe never was
with a huge Bridge no no there's no huge
bridge I can't remember what it was but
there was like a little shop and they
sold at a barrel full of rocks and I was
like oh Ian likes rocks so I filled a
bag up of rocks bought them and then he
was like oh cool rocks it's great
someone dressed up as Ian in our office
for Halloween and walked up to me and
handed me a crystal and I was like it's
happening okay
David Toronto says couldn't pay me 20
grand to go see Taylor Swift
well then I won't I I I I don't know
David
I mean come on it's like a couple hours
20 minutes a lot of money to like sit
there for a couple hours that's my
favorite tweets were the ones that was
like the Taylor Swift you wanted ticket
you wanted so badly was just bought by
some dad who's only heard of her like
one song yeah that's true runaway 25
production says Carl Sagan's I have a
foreboding a foreboding called all of
this everybody for what I'm feeling
especially the low IQ stuff you ever see
that that speech he gave where he talked
about the future and like what was gonna
happen
he's like just talking about pleasure
and stuff and how people are going to
get sucked in and something like that
it's been a while since I saw it it's
kind of like a sort of like an idiocracy
take almost
Heron gaming news says I live with a
mild cognitively delayed I'm I misses
out on my formative years due to a tumor
it's frustrating trying to learn and
people think I can't when I just need
extra help
bummer yeah I can relate
Mr McDonald says it's called the baby
still face experiment
man it's horrifying though you know
those babies were freaking out imagine
what was what was like to have your the
kid in a mask not seeing anyone's face
not knowing how to develop socially for
what two years or what nearly three
nearly three it depends it depends on
how personally devoted to the cause the
parent was right
because and I'd argue the area that you
live in right it's not just the parent's
the parents face is really important for
expression but uh presumably missing out
on interacting with other children
absolutely not developing a lot of
social skills which you know children
need stimulation and interestingly
enough then as you brought up which is
interesting the area the brain drains
such as it is is going to be most severe
in the left-leaning liberal areas
JD Jones says Trump poll looks like a
bot test to see if he solved that
problem interesting what if you know
when he tweeted we shouldn't go to war
with you we shouldn't be at war with
Russia or whatever and then he saw
everyone was like yes we should he said
okay there's Bots maybe he did something
behind the scenes does this poll and now
it's pro-trump and he's like those are
the real people hmm yeah but he would be
talking about what he did no he would at
least but but now anyone paying
attention is like hey he said there's a
whole bunch of bots on here now that
that are messing up the polls yeah he's
running a poll at least we're
speculating he's going to
he's not going to come out and say hey
guys I'm tricking you no yeah that would
ruin the experiment obviously yeah do
you know how he caught the leaker from
Tesla do you see this viral video
no how uh like in 2008 somebody was
leaking yeah somebody was leaking uh
emails and information from Tesla so
what he did was they sent out a
company-wide email
and then in actuality everyone got an
individualized email with a double space
randomly placed somewhere in the email
so they thought it was a company-wide
email they all look the same
then they waited for the email to leak
saw where the double space was and knew
exactly who who had received that email
so he plays games like he he he's he
does these experiments he's not going to
tell you what he's doing maybe maybe
later he will but it's possible he's
gonna have to post a video or he's
holding like his phone up with the date
and time before he puts the poll up
being like this is a test I can prove it
well right if you are doing a data
manipulation or you're doing it you're
conducting a natural experiment you
can't let your subjects know that you're
conducting an experiment well I mean
when you sign up to take a study or do
research at a university you have to
sign off and say yes I know I'm doing
this blah blah blah but you don't in
fact a lot of times when we do studies
it will intentionally throw in bogus
variables
um so to lead the participant to think
that we're studying something that we're
not studying so that they get confused
and think it's about that I'll give you
an example there's this really funny
video I watched a long time ago where
somebody they bring people into a room
and they tell them you're gonna do a
study so fill out this paperwork while
they're filling out the paperwork they
blow smoke under the door and then the
people think that the ACT you have to
trick the person if you told them we're
doing a fire you know preparedness study
they'd be like okay it would change
their reaction the funny thing is when
they would blow the smoke under the door
and it was just one person by themselves
they would go to the door feel it feel
the knob and then start yelling there's
a fire there's a fire something's going
on when they put three people in the
room and blow smoke under the door
people would see the smoke look at each
other yes and then go back to writing
their papers Yep they're looking for
social feedback yeah and that's that
same thing with them and the the
citation is escaping me right now but
where they basically found that if
someone is killed in front of you unless
one person elects to decide to go help
the people will just kind of stand there
and let it happen the other thing too is
uh little kids if they fall usually they
don't cry oh I've heard this if you're
if you have a little kid and they get
hurt you don't act Panic or worried you
laugh and say oh you fell because if you
go oh no oh no then they start crying
like something bad happens I mean this
was sort of a popular trend on I think
Tick Tock for a while parents would be
like holding their kid and walk through
doorway and like yes hit it with their
hand yeah and the kid couldn't see it
and they'd be like oh my gosh are you
okay and the baby would start crying the
baby did not hit the door but the baby
is taking the feedback from you that it
has gotten hurt that's creepy like we
shouldn't do that on Tick Tock for that
you don't want to experiment on children
for social media no I don't understand
oh what could go wrong
Dave's kitchen corner says there was an
episode of the Orville where they
visited a planet where they would upvote
downvote people anyone that got 10
million downvotes was imprisoned not a
good direction to go and a society like
that nobody would want to be famous that
was a Black Mirror episode as well where
it was the uh you had a social credit
score and at some point she couldn't
like rent a car or do anything we're
heading there coming soon to the United
States right nope
that's why they ban people I mean Alex
Jones his his social credit score is
like zero and that's what happens yeah
granted there's only so much you can do
because that dude's famous like I really
don't see a scenario ever where Alex
Jones will be destitute
yeah
he may not be as rich as he once was you
know
Raymond g Stanley Jr says that would be
a great cop show Lewis and ha
I'm excited let's do it
outdoors with the Morgans says when it
crumbles I will trade Lumber and
firewood for eggs bought land in West
Virginia for the same reasons as you if
you come visit password to The High
Ground compound is it's Tim don't shoot
LOL I'll remember that password but I
think everybody else will too some like
super tall fat guy is going to be like
that's Tim don't shoot you're like okay
hey Tim
come on in
what do we got
people mentioning Elon polling Trump's
reinstatement we'll just remind
everybody of that so you can go vote on
it flux Q says you should rename chicken
City to sagama cocktown it's an anagram
for censorship
uh-huh
sagama
I found a 182 Acres I think it was for
like 200 Grand or something oh well
yeah so we can we can make the ligma
Johnson Woodland Preserve ligma Johnson
Woodland Preserve preservation Woodland
yeah
not too far away it's like probably two
hours West of Washington DC or Baltimore
and then uh you know people can hang out
in the Lush Greenery of liquid Johnson
that'd be great so would you keep your
campaign going in Scotland or would you
like reserve well we don't really care
about the Scotland thing that's like we
have a sponsor yeah and it would be
funny if there was a lord ligma Johnson
who for some reason owned 50 000 square
feet in Scotland but if we actually get
this plot of land we can create a public
park preserve you know called ligma
Johnson ligma Johnson Woodland
preservation yeah Lake Titicaca and uh
you know the the Sea Lake balzagna
Seymour butts Trail
but yes we should name everything that
but we'll put up a sign saying like
balzanya you know and uh uh work with
children right see more butts it's
called intellectuals
calm down
Steve Jones says freedom from
consequences is BS the idea of the first
amendment is to exercise it without
consequence
yep as long as you're not free speech
Yes even the the yelling fire in a
crowded movie theater thing is largely a
myth it is yeah so Casey Dennison says
Namor is based in the comics friends
with Spider-Man and Dr Doom interesting
moral and philosophical in the comics
yeah he also just like doesn't care
about anybody's feelings whatsoever he
is pretty based and he has he has wings
on his feet
that actually really did like that when
he was the fight scenes in wakanda
forever it was cool how they had him
like he was basically jumping and they
left that part accurate how interesting
is that we're talking the comics how he
flies or whatever yeah he's got little
wings on his feet it's cute he doesn't
fly up he like jumps on the air
basically oh
yeah it was cool again just interesting
what they are able to leave in I guess
for copyright reasons Wings on his feet
people were complaining I guess that the
actor was a dad bod hero or something
I don't know the weird thing is they
were like
the the fact that
in this article from the from the
Inquirer they're cheering for for Namor
in this movie he's an outright villain
he's like he's a genocidal Maniac who
wants to murder everybody he's basically
killmonger and they're like he's an
anti-hero no he's a bad guy he invades
wakanda for no reason and the funny
thing is wakanda's a landlocked Nation
so like why did he go there
and how did he get there he's like in
Mexico and he can swim just there like
really quick I guess they ride whales
that's the other thing about it oh right
you don't ask questions just consume
product and get excited for next product
is that how the comics were like did
they make more sense or yeah I feel like
I don't really watch all this stuff he's
the king of Atlantis but you but he
really wants that landlocked country no
this is the stuff that's made up the the
Marvel movies are almost all just
completely novel stuff that um they've
made up for the films they're not really
generally some of them are more based on
the comics like the Infinity uh were
stuff but other than that or Civil War
it tends to be largely independent and
do you watch them or like do you skip
them all not anymore I watch them in
2006. or whatever 2008 was I think when
they they started the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and I watched them for a couple
years but not anymore I have no more
interest in it you had to renounce it
they're just like it's gone off the
rails the last thing the the She-Hulk
show messed with my boy Daredevil he's
the only character I really care about
so and even then it's just enough for me
to go oh cool you screwed up something I
like again is there anything I could do
to win you back as like a potential fan
because if you grew up I mean if you if
you read the comics you're more likely
to then I guess yeah they had Black Bolt
blow his own brains out uh in the uh
stupid doctor strange movie no after
that I don't think so it is directly
disrespectful to me as a comic book
reader and you have been directly
disrespectful to me now for
um half a decade if not longer so no I
don't think
they should make a public apology Maya
culpa and I might consider it but
outside of that nope
um I've been done for forever
can I ask you why you left your PhD
program I feel like that's such an
unusual Choice with Academia was it
because oh I got so stressed out yeah
just
when you're you like what you do and you
enjoy doing it you get more and more
workload and I just I had too much at
some point and just went so it took a
sabbatical and then didn't end up this
particle is still going it is now a six
year long sabbatical at any point
Mania K gear Maniac gear says Aiden
you're my hero with the reasonable
expectations of an individual with their
own thoughts and flaws diff Tor he
smuzma
what is that what just happened it means
uh live long and prosper in Vulcan oh
okay well there you go yeah well yeah
means I live long and prosperous means
that peace and long life which is the
response someone says live long and
prosper you say peace and long life oh
very nice
what do we got Bobcat says Luke I am not
the devil but I am proud that I am
exposing the cast of Pop Culture crisis
to some pop culture
okay are you I mean good for you yeah
is this oh this is the Fast and Furious
thing just so everyone knows like I
think it's crazy that there are that
many Fast and Furious how many are there
they're about to come out with their
tenth and part of our bargain is that I
have to finish all of them you do before
the tenth one comes out and if the tenth
one comes out and I haven't finished it
I have to watch that too
um but I just I have never understood
the appeal of The Fast and Furious
movies one and two have not uh won my
heart we had a guest come on the show
and when I was hanging out from the
Green Room he was it was like the day
that this uh bar like wager came to
fruition he was like don't worry one two
three are great after Tokyo Drift it's
all downhill sir that is six movies what
are you talking about yeah the ffcu is
the best Cinematic Universe that's great
like they got to do time travel or space
travel I'm so excited superpowers Mech
suits Transformers yeah it was Tim who
would be like I'd be like I just don't
get fast and furious I've never seen in
them I don't like it which is a little
close-minded of me and he would be like
but they go to space in the latest one
they go to outer space I've never seen
anything Ludacris
resist no well and then I got in I I
wouldn't I don't like cars but then I
got into Top Gear so yeah hold on that's
all right exactly ludicrous in outer
space
it's just if if that was the only
commercial it was like Fast and the
Furious ludicrous is in outer space I'd
be like okay when do we go yeah I'm
there oh no you are easily entertained
but it's funny you know is it have a
good time and enjoy the little things in
life if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
no members only shows on Fridays but you
can check out our full Library we have a
bunch of really awesome guests of the
past week and the weeks prior you can
become uh you can follow us on Instagram
at timcastirl or basically anywhere you
can follow me at timcast smash that like
button Aiden you want to shout anything
out uh just the video that I'm working
on which is about the the Dark Side of
morality is I think the tentative title
and because all of this greed and envy
and self-interest it all comes out of a
place of the left people probably on the
left feeling is if
they are doing something moral and good
for other people even if it ultimately
only really benefits themselves and
that's a very very scary I think place
to be but that'll be some time I've been
what is your what is your channel oh
yeah it's Aidan Paladin at the on
YouTube and on Twitter so just a y d i n
Paladin p-a-l-a-d-i-n right on
oh uh I'm Hannah clear brimlow I'm a
writer for timcast.com you can find me
on Instagram at Hannah claire.b you
should also follow Tim cast news on
Twitter it's great you can see all of
our content there and I think that's the
only thing I have to shut up are you on
Twitter I am on Twitter uh but I don't
talk on Twitter I'm just there to get
people's uh comments so you can follow
me but it will be boring uh I'm not a
bot Elon Musk thank you so much for
coming and sharing some of your findings
I thought they were fascinating uh Karen
Claire you were tolerable uh so thank
you also for coming here my website is
Luke uncensored.com I made a very
interesting video that's titled it's
Landon Landon uncensored.com and and
it's titled how to take care of your
balls that are under attack it's a real
video a very serious one you could watch
that get exclusive merchandise be a part
of a conversation on the Forum all on
Luke uncensored.com
I am Serge search.com watching these two
guys argue it's been fun have a good
weekend guys we will see you all we're
gonna have Clips up throughout the
weekend but other than that we will see
you all on Monday thanks for hanging out
cheers